joe biden held the press conference for
the first time in what almost two and a
half months
and he said some pretty uh outrageous
things i guess one that really caught my
attention was when he
he effectively said that we will stop
russia if they invade ukraine unless
it's like a minor incursion then we'll
talk about it and many people were like
yo did he just green light russia to
invade ukraine saying we don't know if
we'll respond
and i'm torn because i'm like well i
don't want to get involved in a war with
ukraine but perhaps the way we do avoid
the war is by being like russia don't do
it neither of us want a war but if
you're outright gonna be like yeah go
ahead and do it then you're gonna get a
war then biden will use that invasion as
pretext for escalated action and then in
my opinion they want war they'll start a
war because they want to boost joe
biden's approval ratings because war
tends to do that for for presidents but
we'll see considering how joe biden
completely screwed up afghanistan
i think ultimately the dude is just kind
of out of it so here's what happens on
twitter we get a viral trend 25th
amendment
this means people are saying joe biden
should be removed from the presidency
and the funny thing is even though
everyone should agree with that even on
the left the left just comes out and
starts arguing about trump and i'm just
like i don't i don't think they
understand that a lot of the people who
are saying joe biden ain't with it would
probably agree trump said stupid things
too and we're not talking about that but
we'll get into that we got a bunch of
other stories a lot having to do with uh
with joe biden we also have the story
about npr lying about uh neil gorsuch
gorsuch not wearing a mask and sotomayor
not wanting to be you know in the
chambers with them because of it we at
tim cast actually wrote that story up
npr got it wrong
both justices have denied saying it's
fake news so here we here we go a major
lesson in fake news we'll talk about all
this stuff plus the 5g rollout
disrupting airlines
this is getting weird i thought the 5g
stuff was a conspiracy theory but uh
sure joining us to talk about all of
this and social media censorship is the
ceo of getter jason miller thanks for
coming man thanks for having me do you
want to introduce yourself yeah
absolutely jason miller i'm the ceo of
getter fastest growing social media
platform in world history up to just
under four and a half million users we
got to a million users after three days
about a million and a half after 10 days
so we're fastest to one two three four
by comparison facebook took about 10
months to get to their first million so
this thing is taken off like a rocket
ship and really the principle is on free
speech and that's the the big
differential between us and the big tech
platforms which i know we're going to go
into a whole lot we've got a whole bunch
of this show so yeah so if you're if
you're
logged on here and you're watching or
catching on the podcast i know you got a
lot of questions we'll be diving into it
but yes uh so super chat us because
we're we're gonna you know we're not
gonna hold back we're gonna ask
everything and uh anything and
everything uh but where did you work
before you were doing uh getter you were
so uh so i worked for president trump on
both his 2016 and 2020 campaigns and
then after the 2020 campaign i stayed
and worked for him for about about six
months or so so i led the effort on his
second impeachment defense uh which we
went through which is another circus we
can dive into the details on that a
couple of fun stories on that one uh and
then worked for president trump up until
june but during that process while i was
working for president trump and all the
social media platforms and people who
are starting platforms were coming to
the present saying we want to get you on
board want to show you the technology
i got connected with the getter folks
and right away when i saw it as said
this is this one's the ticket this of
everything that i saw and i probably
only saw about a half dozen dan scavino
probably saw 30 or 40 different ones i
said this has to be it and so actually
steve bannon made the connection that's
how i ended up getting uh connected with
him and then the rest is history yeah
i've already got 200 and like 12 000
followers on getter and and that's
separate because you know a lot of
people brought up that you had a
combined follower of other socials but
you separate now specifically on getter
i've only been using it for a couple
weeks and i've barely posted hundreds of
thousands and the engagement is through
the roof
the cool thing is on the engagement it's
a passionate community because you have
a lot of people who want a statistic a
lot of people don't realize when
president trump was d platformed about
20 to 25 percent of all his supporters
quit social media yeah now they didn't
necessarily cancel all their accounts
but they said okay i'm tired of big tech
this whole the system is rigged the game
is rigged uh i'm not going to be on this
anymore with president trump making the
noise uh that he's going to get back
into the social media arena a lot of
people are coming off the sidelines and
getting back active so it's a passionate
community people are glad that it's not
twitter that's not facebook it's not
zuckerberg coming in or youtube putting
up their warnings about climate change
and all this stuff so it's a passionate
group
we're going to talk about your policies
people have been banned your plans for
the future and we'll get into all that
so thanks for coming we got luke as well
hey guys i got a very simple message uh
regulate your government not your name
not your neighbors and i think if a lot
of people did that the world would be a
better place if you agree and want the
t-shirt you could get it on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com because you do
i'm here this should be an interesting
conversation i definitely have a lot of
questions i want to ask and ian that's a
pretty cool emf free little hoodie
headphone you're wearing there now this
is from you you think i don't know about
this stuff it's a gift i received from
tim and it is an electromagnetic
frequency radiation
shielding mechanism oh apparently it
shields 99.9 of the radiation this is
good for me because i usually sleep days
and i'm up at night because the psychic
energy is just
uh it's fluxing through my brain i don't
know but i can feel the people's pain
and love and it's very intense so this
has helped quite a bit i don't know if
it's psychosomatic or if it's working i
can't tell you it's it's psychosomatic
and i sure think it is but it is a legit
it's a high-end tin foil hat
what's it disappeared now that we're on
the subject i got a gift for tim oh my
god i've mentioned this before
i've delivered what is it tell people
what it is this is an anthony fauci
bobblehead and it is the fouchiest of
all fouchy bobbles that i've had where'd
you get that that's amazing it looks
fine i don't know it's actually got some
weight to it it was on ebay
yeah that's
his glasses come off too this is like
the modern day equivalent of chucky look
so thank you tim and i'm i'm happy to
have gotten you that gift as well thank
you very much
made indonesia okay australia oh cool
another slave camp
camp yeah i i just need to say this one
more time to make it very clear for the
camera this anthony fauci bobblehead was
made in china
i love it well i don't have anything as
cool to show as an emf hoodie or a
vouchy bobble head but i am also here
pushing buttons in the corner happy to
be here it's gonna be a great
conversation before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
help support all of our journalists the
work we do here on the show as a member
you'll get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim castairl
podcast we're going to have our special
members only uncensored show going live
about 11 or so p.m you're not going to
want to miss it and you will also get an
ad-free experience on the website so if
you like the work we do and you want to
help sign up at timcast.com but don't
forget also to smash the like button
right now subscribe to this channel and
share the url wherever you can because
that grassroots word of mouth is the
most powerful thing cnn dumps all this
money in advertising youtube puts them
on the front page all we have is your
willpower if you like the show you share
it otherwise you don't and maybe for
today everyone should share it on getter
and then make it make everybody see it
because we're hearing from the ceo and
that being said let's get into that
first story we got it from npr
now i used npr on purpose as the source
of this because we're going to rag on
them later
biden acknowledges his team should have
done more covid testing earlier now
that's the headline but the point of
this story is marking the end of his
first year in office with a long
wide-ranging formal press conference
biden said it had been a year of
challenges but also a year of enormous
progress citing stats on vaccinations
job creation and cuts to child poverty
the real story here is that joe biden
had a press conference of course npr
likes to soften the blow for the man
because right now on twitter 25th
amendment is trending now here's where
it gets funny
initially it started trending because
people critical of joe biden which
includes the independent uh not
unaffiliated voter and republican voters
moderates liberals post liberals
conservatives libertarians they're all
basically saying yo i think something's
wrong with joe biden he's saying a bunch
of crazy stuff he's like inviting war
with with russia and ukraine and then it
gets taken over by
the left who starts calling people
maggots
screaming the 25th amendment and then
they just start showing you know donald
trump speaking and other stuff
i think the reality is
there's one clip in particular that
really exemplifies this someone asked
joe biden directly why it is that so
many people think he's in cognitive
decline and his response was i i have no
idea and it's funny because that's
actually the correct answer joe biden
has no idea right well so so i find this
i find this fascinating that we're
finally getting this press conference
from joe biden
and that people are using it as an
opportunity to basically be like this
man should not be president
i mean i i think people came to that
realization as soon as he came into
office i think people came to that
realization when he wasn't even running
a campaign and the media was running it
for him but there's a lot of major
bombshells in this kind of press
conference that he released
real quick i like that you called it a
kind of press conference yeah i mean
yeah i mean he was there for two hours
took 24 questions let's admit that's
that's sort of impressive for biden
especially at his age but he talked
about a lot of nonsense he was
congratulating himself on his
afghanistan pull out he said that
america is making enormous progress
meanwhile we have record coveted cases
the united states government right now
under his administration is getting 400
million and 95 masks over 400 million
covid tests when the united kingdom is
literally getting rid of their vax
passport system and mask mandates what
he's doing is the complete opposite of
what should be doing and let's not also
forget he pretty much invited putin to
invade ukraine which is an absolutely
huge bombshell with a lot of significant
ramifications
and everything to me look
biden should fire every single person at
white house immediately and i'll tell
you why the reason why they went to this
press conference because tomorrow is the
one year anniversary of his inauguration
so what they're doing from a strategic
thing in their minds not very smart is
they want to get ahead of it i could
just see him in the briefing room now
with pepper patty there saying hey we're
going to have this one-year anniversary
we got to frame the headlines let's go
out there and talk about everything
great that we're doing so joe biden gets
out there and literally assumes
responsibility for every malady that is
affecting the united states right now so
basically he gets up there and he lists
everything going wrong here's what we're
doing about it we're making great doing
progress so oh they're again they're
going to have some headlines for their
one year anniversary tomorrow i don't
think it's the headlines they were
looking for i don't know though you
think the media is actually going to be
fair and criticize joe biden so i i got
to tell you this it's here's the thing
you got to keep keep in mind about
reporters is they're basically
uh uh
well they're they're alligators right
they got to eat and so they are it's a
matter of time for how how quickly they
turn on someone but they're going to
turn on you i mean they you know the
easiest way to not get eaten is to not
look like food well joe biden right now
looks like a big juicy cheeseburger
people are angry
i can't remember who was saying it but
they were like when people go to the
grocery store they're angry when they
see their products are skyrocketing and
cost they're angry when they see the gas
prices they're angry i see these memes
man there's a meme of uh somebody all it
is is someone pumping gas and it was
like in 2019 or something and it was
like a dollar seventy and i was just
like wow
gas was under two bucks
i remember at that point you know i was
driving and i saw the gas prices and i
was shocked because when i was 18 and
working in chicago
the gas prices were hitting two dollars
and it was a big deal and now here we
are wonder trump and it's back under two
bucks and i was like is that crazy how
is is that and now the gas prices are
skyrocketing in california what was that
like nine bucks in one once was it like
a while ago was it seven i thought it
was i thought it was more like six but
yeah you might be right there was like
one particular town where it got got
like really really high maybe maybe nine
was i thought everyone drove prius is
out there the people still get gasoline
and teslas yeah guilty and uh out here
in the middle of nowhere it's been in
like the three to like mid three dollars
range people go to the gas station
they're angry
i'll tell you this from pr standpoint
joe biden coming out and reminding
everybody of that is probably not a good
idea but to your point you're right i
think journalists are going to be like
hey a lot of people are really pissed
off why everything happening around them
hey joe biden talked about it there's
our angle the other thing to keep in
mind too is that ratings and
subscriptions are down for everywhere in
the mainstream media with no trump trump
basically he created one of the
industries he helped the most was the
mainstream media he gave everybody
ratings boost right now all the
subscriptions ratings are down you saw
was at cnn's down 90 whatever it is so
they have to turn because if it's just
softball city they're not going to get
any ratings even look on the drive out
here i was even listening to fake news
cnn and even they were turning on him
and it was amazing to hear you know the
jake tappers and the wolf blitzers and
all these folks being critical of biden
you know they're saying you know clean
up on was the one line i think dana bass
used was clean up on the state
department aisle or something like that
with the ukraine thing i mean they have
uh they see those ratings down 90 you
better believe they're going to turn on
joe biden what are we at 29 democrats
announcing their retirement was that it
or was it 27
i don't know i don't know those exact
numbers but but my point is just real
quick
even the democrat politic democratic
politicians in congress are starting to
jump [ __ ] yeah there's it's only so long
for those two dudes to hold up bernie
right
until the weight gets too strong for
them the weekend burns i'm making a
reference bernie sanders no no no i'm
making a reference the weekend of
bernie's great movie classic movie about
a dead guy that two guys were carrying
around to be alive i'm not going to
spoil the plot for you definitely
a 30-year-old
exactly by the corporate media the two
people holding him up is the
bureaucratic corrupt system and of
course the corporate media journalists
that weight of bernie is getting very
heavy and they're starting to let go
because it's too absurd not to call out
biden on his failures for him to stand
and talk to the american people and say
what he did in afghanistan was a success
is absolutely crazy he blamed everything
because he wasn't able to pass the build
back better bill he blamed by the way
the new hampshire governor for that he
said he the new hampshire governor is
one of the biggest roadblocks to build
back better which would have solved
everything no no no no buildback better
would have created more government which
he has been implementing and using which
has been
absolutely eviscerating our current way
of life destroying any kind of wealth
destroying any kind of future young
people have in this country because when
you look at his policies these are the
policies of the corporatist the most
corrupt special interests and lobbyists
in washington dc that are absolutely
getting away with murder and able to get
away with whatever they want under his
administration which he's acting like a
larger puppet for as he's really a
representative of them let's let me read
this we got uh charlie spearing says
quote i didn't over promise as joe biden
says he outperformed in his first year
josh hawley responds store shelves are
empty prices are soaring real wages are
declining american cities are engulfed
in violence the border is controlled by
the cartels and parents are treated as
terrorists while actual terrorists go
free when do the dems seriously consider
the 25th amendment
and then what kamala harris
is that's that's a scary notion you know
one of the things to tell you a sure
sign uh in politics when uh someone
who's in office or candidate when
they're losing when their idea to turn
something around is all tactics as
opposed to strategy now this can a
little bit nuanced but i'm putting my
politics hat back on for a moment here
so joe biden
in addition to listing out everything
going around the country his grand
strategy was to get out of the white
house i have to get out of the white
house i have to tour the country i gotta
go talk to people between covid and
between things going on here in
washington i'm not getting face to face
if i do this things are gonna turn
around that's a tactic that's a small
thing like hey we're gonna hold press
conferences on wednesdays or i'm gonna
go out and we're gonna he blamed it on
the communications effort said we have
to talk to people better okay when
you're talking about stuff as a
president like that of the president
united states you know the whole thing's
disaster that's why i said claim pepper
patty circle back they all need to be
fired because so disastrous the
headlines tomorrow are just a nightmare
and just to be clear peppermint patty is
jen sackey right yes yes who's actually
she's somewhat decently nice but
i know it's almost fair it's funny you
called her that i was fair in politics
and like if you're discussing changing
strategy instead of changing tactics
you're talking about more of a global a
general uh
behaviors like how are we going to deal
with climate change as opposed to
uh
so or is climate change what you know
how big of a deal is climate change like
that would be more of a strategy
conversation right so here's here's the
reality for biden is that biden has one
speed today he talked about he tried to
he literally said what this was a buried
line i think i posted this on getter he
said that we have to contrast
against the other side more he has a one
speed and that's to go and say i'm not
trump and so usually what happens in
election is joe biden says i'm not trump
he ends up winning and then the first
year second year you don't have someone
to say i'm not trump your your ratings
go down and then you get closer to the
next election then you have a chance to
contrast against someone else that's the
only way that biden has a chance of
succeeding is saying i'm not trump we
saw him pivot to that he couldn't even
say anything negative about mitch
mcconnell if you guys saw that he was
like oh i'm friends with mitch mcconnell
he's great but the strategy thing is joe
biden has to go and take it right now
he's playing the whack-a-mole with all
these little things a strategic change
would be to go and say rather than
getting mired in all the hill
legislation i'm getting out there and
launch a new initiative and get behind
and say uh this administration is about
you know the chicken in every pot or you
know this is about uh you know helping
this group of voters or something but we
need so strategically or he says look
right now we're on a fight against the
ccp or a fight against putin and russia
some kind of strategic shift from
domestic to uh international that's a
strategic shift but just saying i'm
going to get out and go talk to people
around the country
that's do you think anyone who's pumping
up and paying five or six dollars a
gallon for gas is going to give a you
know what he's going to get out of the
white house more no
no not at all it's just
without trump
they really don't have anything and
that's that was even during the election
now we're getting into 2022
and it looks like with democrats
retiring they see the writing on the
wall the media you mentioned some of
them now turning on joe biden they see
the writing on the wall let me tell you
something that's that's substantive
though i want to talk about this story
right here the first thing i want to do
is show you this clip where i said holy
ish they want war they profit from war
listen to this from joe biden so i think
what you're going to say hold on let me
let me make sure i get the audio right
because it may be playing properly but
i'm just going to double check our
sources real quick and now i'm going to
play it okay here we go
so i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having a fight about
what to do and not do etc
it depends on what it does if it's a
minor incursion yeah and a lot of people
immediately went like why would you
downplay the u.s response to russia
invading another country in europe
because limited war baby henry
kissinger's let's do proxy wars and take
little pieces of this and that they've
segmented it into china russia and the
us three superpowers get to split the
earth amongst them you're absolutely
correct well the british are also on
that list they're absolutely correct
they're like limited war we've accepted
it uh final answer elaborate right now
well well the proxy wars that are
happening are very profitable especially
when you have these big major kind of
states fighting each other the west
versus the east and they already happen
in syria they already happened in yemen
and if they could advance it towards
another place like ukraine this only of
course benefits the military-industrial
complex now this could be a two-prong
response here understanding uh biden's
statements one is that he's old he see
now he doesn't know what he's talking
about the second one is that he's
inviting russia in because at the long
term this is going to work in favor of
the neoconservative of the deep state of
the military or industrial complex that
of course is going to be striving for
this but there's two other important
pieces of information to consider here a
couple weeks ago the biden
administration according to some sources
even went to ukraine and said would it
be okay if you just give up some of your
sovereign land to to russia so this is
something that has already been an
underlining policy that has happened
before so that's why i'm also calling
bunk on the white house's latest
statement because they just issued a
clarification on biden's statement
saying that if russia invades of course
there's going to be a swift and severe
response and obviously they're just
trying to cover the bad press and the
bad reaction they're getting from this
but geopolitically the situation is
complex russia has been moving their
troops towards ukraine the united states
and nato have been moving their troops
towards russia as well so the situation
is getting tense and i wouldn't be
surprised if there was another proxy war
that of course is going to be perpetual
warfare as ian said the henry kissinger
doctrine never-ending war for profit
just want to show this cnn headline real
quick
biden predicts russia will move into
ukraine but says minor incursion may
prompt discussion over consequences wow
even cnn couldn't sugarcoat that one
although they tried though right now
that was a this is cnn moment you know
look i want to agree with somebody you
said a moment ago about the the
expansion on the the military side if
you went back and listened to biden's
answer he said in fact we're already
going to increase the number of troops
that we have he said poland and then he
also uh the other country for the other
country you mentioned but he lists
two countries and then he goes if they
go and move into ukraine and do some
different things but he was all ready to
i mean that's the thing that no one's
talking about he already announced u.s
troop expansions uh into two different
countries is part of his answer like
he's already thought through this i mean
he definitely has the direction he wants
to go but you know one of the points i'd
make a little bit of the buried lead on
this when we see whether it's putin or
she which i spent a lot of time talking
about the ccp and what they're doing
around the world as soon as biden was
declared the winner that's when these
guys started going on offense and the
real reason why we know that i think
both biden uh excuse me but she and
putin take action is if biden's the
one-term president they're gonna go and
make their moves now while he's in as
opposed to waiting till whoever comes
next do you remember when biden was i
think he said a u.n meeting or was it g7
and he kept saying libya over and over
again instead of syria
i i assure you she and and putin see
that and they look at each other and you
know putin's like is she if we invade
ukraine he might accidentally invade
libya instead
so but you think it's a you know i'm
half joking imagine if if joe biden is
in the situation room
and he says directly to to his generals
we gotta we gotta get more more troops
on the ground in libya you get get to it
and they're like sir do you mean you
heard me and they're like okay he got
bitten wrong why but but here's the
important people to understand
if the generals hear joe biden say libya
and they leave saying well we know he
really meant syria so we'll go with
syria instead what if he really did mean
libya
if he did mean syria when he said libya
and the generals say
your order is sir and then they start
sending troops to libya what
i'm sorry man i understand that joe
biden misspoke but he said true not a
chaperone of pressure and batacaf care
as well
you've got to be very precise when
you're talking about missile strikes and
nukes and war
and i'm pretty sure putin she and even
you know kim jong-un and any one of our
adversaries you know in iran and
venezuela are like there's a good chance
that if we invade joe biden will order a
missile strike in the wrong country
let's go for it i i disagree there uh
because putin realizes that the
president isn't really the president of
the united states he made very important
comments a couple years ago specifically
talking about how even presidents change
there's always men in dark suits that
implement the same kind of foreign
policy that has been in some ways always
the same
for a very long time for decades now and
it's important to understand i think
he's just a puppet i think the
military-industrial complex knows
exactly what they're doing the language
from the biden administration and
intelligence agencies has been concise
here and they said russia will stage a
false flag attack and will launch an
invasion of russia it's only a matter of
time until russia invades ukraine russia
will invade ukraine those are the
talking points of the intelligence
agency of the biden administration right
after the cia had just had a secret
mission in kiev where he came back from
and this information came uh came out
that they're going to do a false flag
and many people are speculating that
kiev gave the head of the cia this
information the cia gave it to cnn and
that's why the american public has now
regurgitated this information false
flags have always started a lot of world
wars
and important wars throughout recorded
human history so there's there's the
rhetoric is hot here and it's and it's
pretty crazy i don't know if it'll be
world war three but i think
i'd be willing to bet within this year
russia invades ukraine joe biden says
something like trinidad shabbat a
pressure but it's because there's a plan
in action and we don't know he's
muttering about but we do respond and
this is i think because the democrats
are losing many are retiring joe biden's
approval reading is in the absolute is
just destroyed and they need a
distraction and they need something to
try and boost their approval ratings and
offer up something not just really quick
i'm not saying there's going to be a
world war but i'm saying the only thing
as you were saying i was going to make
that point
the only thing that could stop the
negative viewpoint of the biden
administration the the poll numbers is a
conflict is a war and i don't see it as
as uh because there's mutual absurd uh
assured destruction if russia and the
united states fight each other it's
going to be just like syria the united
states is going to be sending more arms
sending in more uh you know military
hardware more u.s tax paying dollars
will be sent to ukraine russia will of
course influence that region they
already have been fighting for years now
so it's only
it only makes sense that the conflict's
escalating and is going to ask so
this is one of the things to remember
the contrast between biden and trump for
example is biden tonight very much
sounded like a u.s senator he didn't
sound like a president sounded like a
senator so when he was talking about
even their domestic agenda he's going
through i like this part of legislation
not that i'm going to try to save this
part not the other he went through and
gave this very kind of methodology he
walked himself into the trap was he
tried to turn to nuance and give his
answer about we'll see on the minor
incursion all of that i mean obviously
we know the last time that putin went
rolling into ukraine i mean he took
crimea back i mean so they already have
the president the biden's not going to
do anything so i think what happens is
putin definitely goes i don't think it's
a full takeover of ukraine but it's
enough to rattle the saber make himself
look good at home biden says well i'm
gonna give you double triple secret
sanctions uh and effectively then putin
wins the day and biden looks weak but i
think they know that biden is uh we're
as opposed to trump who basically told
uh well obviously with putin he took one
strategy of kind of doing the buddy
routine with kim jong-un he said fire
and fury will drop the bombs and wipe
you off the face of the earth guess what
deter kim jong-un quite a bit
absolutely ian you had something to say
yeah this is why i think limited war and
not total war this is the kissinger
limited war doctrine where they wanna
they want conflict not in the homeland
because you don't want to destroy your
infrastructure and they don't want to go
to nukes with russia so they'd like to
just military industrial complex the
hell out of ukraine
buy and sell a lot of weapons destroy a
lot of bombs over cities and just level
i mean that's what they did in vietnam
that was a limited war they didn't want
to go to war with russia or china and
this has been building for a very long
time especially with the united states
trying to build their sphere of
influence trying to get ukraine from
russian influence towards a european
nato influence we saw john mccain in
kiev literally lead the marches down
there trying to overthrow their
government there was a very violent
revolution that hurt a lot of people it
was all against corruption the ukrainian
people were dealing with a corrupt
government but they got another corrupt
government in response to it with
biden's fingerprints all over it with
his son's business involvements in it
and of course also the president of the
united states donald trump at the time
who sent lethal weapons to ukraine which
was an absolute huge escalation
according to russia and this is why
russia is pissed off because they're
seeing nato they're seeing the us
weapons going closer and closer to their
border and they're saying we need to
strike back in order to push back
against this nonsense the secretary of
state even a couple weeks ago said nato
never agreed not to build up on on
russia's border which is absolutely
untrue there's a lot of documents
there's a lot of agreements between
russia and nato and the united states
saying that the united states won't be
building up a lot of their military
hardware on there so this is a very
escalating
hot situation that could turn very
drastic for the people of ukraine which
is absolutely sad as these but isn't it
better politicians just rule lives which
is insane i think trump's strategy with
sending weapons to ukraine was hey we're
not going to get involved in this
conflict we'll sell you some weapons
it's all on you whereas biden and the
neolibs and neocons were setting up you
know uh getting hunter biden in barisma
trying to work you know energy uh
companies there's a reason why they want
to get ukraine into you know
aligned with the western forces trump's
attitude was america first we don't want
to be at war with these countries here
are some weapons it's your issue yeah i
mean take a look at me do you think
germany or france or anyone else in nato
was watching biden tonight a were they
you know not laughing or shaking their
head and be like what the blank is this
or shaking in their boots exactly or
saying exactly saying this thing they
don't have our back bring trump back can
we get trump back in the white house i
mean that's where i mean you know that
uh
um you know that mccrea you know when
you have macron and johnson and even
though angela uh has left um olaf uh
shoulders i'm sure they're like let's
get trump back at least we knew where
that guy stood well well biden continued
trump's policies of providing lethal
weapons to ukraine so that also is
escalating the situation it's it's a
very complex situation because we should
actually see it from both perspectives
we should see it from the russian side
from the ukrainian side and from the
american side because each side has
their own particular version of events
i'm trying to just to tell people the
version of events how i see it but again
there's different pr there's different
propaganda from each different side and
it's truly a a very dangerous situation
that i believe will be a limited war
just like ian is saying with the henry
kissinger doctrine that makes most sense
but even with that there still is a
probability of it escalating and
becoming extremely dangerous for
everyone else and that's why war should
never be the answer diplomacy should be
the way to move forward here and biden
is just standing there and saying yeah
just invade yeah i think that the u.s
president no u.s president is probably
responsible for getting us into war
these days i think it's more deep state
and like administrative officials that
are pulling the strings but a president
seems to be able to stop it from
happening at least put the brakes on
keep my look everything's interconnected
so she watching this is looking saying
hey taiwan you look pretty juicy that's
the one where i do think i think that
she i don't know how long after the
olympics he goes and makes his move
that's the one where i think putin goes
and takes a little part of ukraine
chalks up a victory he gets his win uh
he stops the nato expansion uh into uh
uh or the eu expansion pardon me into
ukraine some of the other things but i
do think she goes all the way and goes
for taiwan what gets me this invasion of
iraq and afghanistan the united's pulled
off the united states pulled off i can't
in good in good like conscience
say hey china don't invade taiwan
because it's like dude i just supported
a country for 20 years that invaded a
country and still in iraq so
but at the same time i can't condone
to ccp invading taiwan i can't condone i
think the people in ukraine got a very
tough lesson in american foreign policy
when they saw what happened in
afghanistan
so i i feel bad for the people of
ukraine they're in an extremely tough
situation on one side you have russia on
another side you have nato and joe biden
who pulled off one of the worst
withdrawals
literally arming our enemies literally
if you you couldn't pull off a worse
move than you could even try to when it
came to what biden did with afghanistan
and that's still fresh in a lot of
people's minds especially
internationally especially in ukraine
who are sitting there like man we're
screwed let me ask this though some
people have pointed out in the chat
if russia moves on ukraine
china goes for taiwan instantly what do
you think possibility yeah i think it uh
and look the order could be the other
way around but there's there's always
safety in numbers that make it two-front
war because then you have nato you have
apac you have that um uh you have
everyone who's looking at so i think
that's probably uh that's probably
pretty accurate although i think i do
think that both happen uh regardless but
it speeds up and expedites the action of
such uh if they both do it or what if
one does it yeah let's say
this year
russia invades ukraine it seems like
it's likely i mean or at the very least
the u.s is saying that there will be a
false flag or something happens let's
say that china does move on taiwan what
do you think the administration's
response is going to be you think
they'll be able to handle this or do you
think it just falls apart i think it
falls apart and i tell you the other
thing too just especially as i'm
traveling around and push the platform
in a lot of different countries
japan is freaked the heck out japan is
looking out and saying hey if they take
taiwan we're next oh yeah and they are
the entire region is absolutely in panic
saying
at least again you know we knew where
things were with trump but biden we saw
his response tonight he talked like a
u.s senator he said i'm going to give
them the toughest sanctions they're
going to be you they're on restriction
they do not get to ride their bike for
two weeks uh and it's that's about how
tough it was this is why american
foreign policy is so mind-boggling
because it's self-defeating it's
shooting itself in the foot you have a
situation where russia and china don't
like each other there's an opportunity
to work with one another have peaceful
cooperation have economic uh incentives
to work with europe and the more that
the united states puts up these
neoconservatives the more we push push
away russia the more russia becomes
closer to china and they could act in
unison and strategically that would be
the move that they would pull off that
would put the united states in a very
particularly difficult position on the
world stage that wouldn't only just
question its hegemony but alt-right
changed the whole understanding of how
the world kind of operates so this is
this could also be a deliberate effort
to bring down the united states with the
this kind of viewpoint of what the world
sees america as especially under biden
there's no way the u.s can maintain its
its empire if there's no way it can
maintain the military bases everywhere
that russia moves on ukraine we're split
on two fronts the us does not have the
organizational power does not have the
cohesion we've got viral videos of you
know women in the army doing tick tock
dances we've got wokeness and critical
race theory
i gotta be honest if xi jinping is is
looking at taiwan he's probably laughing
about what he sees in the u.s media
having do with our military vladimir
putin the same thing there was that
viral campaign where the russian
military ad of it's all black and it's
all gray and green and there's this guy
and he's all sweating he's ripped and
he's doing push-ups and he jumps out of
a plane and he lands he got the mask on
his arms and he's like ah and he's
fighting and then you have the um the us
army ad of a little girl saying i have
two moms
and i'm like that's cool i guess i don't
know how that's going to instill fear in
our adversaries and the people who want
to do wrong by us and our friends
but i guess
this is what we end up with yeah
something tells me that she and putin do
not sit around debating whether or not
they're going to fund transgender
surgeries that's that's probably not
something that they spend much time on i
want to make sure i'm being fair too at
the same time as this ad comes out and
everyone criticized the army ad for
having this like woke diversity thing we
still have the marine corps which is
putting out ads of like there's one
where a guy he sees like weird
futuristic sci-fi hologram selling
sneakers and then he like swings at one
and then falls and slams and also he's
in a swamp and he gets up and he's armed
and it's the marine corps and it's much
much more hardcore much more similar to
the russian ad so
that's a fair point i want to make sure
there's we're giving the reasonableness
the rationality here but um
i don't think russia is putting together
ads to convince their military service
member in any branch
to be woke diverse comfy cuddly pastel
bean bags safety spaces and all that
stuff
so unfortunately for us
or maybe even you know there's still a
light at the end of the tunnel maybe we
shouldn't be the world police maybe we
we never wanted to be donald trump was
very critical of of this aspect of
america and maybe this will
you know get us back to america first
policies make us focus on our own
borders maybe biden's failures will cost
us our empirical status in a sense but
we'll end up with a stronger economy at
home with the working class being you
know better supported with secure
borders
but we know that's not going to happen
we know that especially not under biden
at least not till we get another a
different president in the white house i
mean the fact of the matter is trump had
this very much disposition the the
america first uh and look a lot of
criticism a lot of heat from people
saying you should be doing things to
help out obviously sent the
military the missiles to ukraine but
said you got to go and handle it on your
own but people knew where trump stood
and so with north korea that was when he
put through the big economic sanctions
on china so he had that approach
he was aggressive he was out in front a
number of these things the thing with
biden is i don't even think biden knows
what his strategy is he says oh we're
going to go and you know we'll talk
we'll have some different things and
it's he's not making friends with
anything he's basically just sending the
the signal to everyone that we're weak
americans were weak and that's when
things especially as i've been traveling
around even like i said we're talking
about this before we started even the
countries where people trump was way
upside down he's like 10 favorable
they're saying at least with trump
people wouldn't steamroll the us or the
us's allies biden is inviting all of the
aggression from she and putin because
he's so weak i mean it was that was a
disgrace to the country what we saw in
that two-hour press conference that he
had tonight it's embarrassing but that's
just who joe biden is
my i tweeted out that's our joe
because we know it it you know i was
watching uh we were i remember what we
were watching earlier but i saw a
commercial for jimmy kimmel and i just
looked up and i said to everybody you
know it's crazy that there are people
who still live in that world
that fake media handcrafted narrative
world people still live in there it's
the matrix
you know i guess i can envy those
poor ignorant fools but ignorance is
bliss so that bliss i mean sounds great
turn on the tv joe biden's great he's
charismatic and confident everything's
better than ever and for those of us
that have taken that red pill and popped
out of the matrix we're like wow this is
really bad but i'll tell you what at
least we can buy our emergency food and
build our bunkers so that when it does
hit the fan we'll be okay for at least a
few months right i'm kidding calm down
everybody i don't think it's a bombastic
statement to say that the american
empire is going down and that there are
special interests in this country that
are making sure that it gets destroyed
from the inside and i think one way they
will do that is by of course
creating more afghanistan situations
creating more foreign policy failures
creating more foreign policy that
absolutely lets the entire world down
it's absolutely crazy to act and play
like this tough guy when again diplomacy
is the biggest strength that you could
show if you could resolve problems
without needing to saber rattle or start
a war or kill people that's one of the
biggest strengths that you could have on
this world and and
you know more than ever we need
diplomats but but now we have a
situation that is very very dangerous
and only going to be expanding from here
and
i think the united states is being
destroyed deliberately and i think
foreign policy
is a major ingredient to that
destruction and i just add on that is
that the only way that diplomacy works
is if they think that you have the
fortitude to back it up or if they think
that you're tough because i agree with
you i look i don't want us to go sending
more troops over to europe or to asia to
anywhere else i mean it's
i thought it was good what trump did
with drawing troops from a number of the
countries from around the world but if
people don't think that you actually act
or back up any of your allies on this
then they're going to go and they're
going to be aggressive and then guess
what's going to happen then you get to
real war
i think we're headed towards real war
i mean at least
we've
with what china's been doing you know we
we have them going near our waters in
hawaii going near our waters in alaska
we've had that that meeting with anthony
blinken where china basically just said
the united states is not coming from a
position of power
so when we're at that you know we can
call it thucydides trap maybe the simple
way to put it is not any special kind of
you know named idea it's just that china
is growing in power and as their power
grows their military might grows they
become more confident and they start
looking in america saying you know what
we're not we're not shorter than you
anymore we've grown up we've matured and
we're powerful screw you and the u.s
being the old dog going to be like no
way but we got joe biden
so we can keep in mind that russia and
china both have similar uh issues that
they're facing where putin and xi have
to watch their flank internally as well
part of the reason why putin does the
whole saber rattling is because that's a
strategy of saying you know what i want
to shore up my domestic base by going
get everyone focused on the fact that
ukraine is we own ukraine these terrible
horrible people from the west are trying
to impose on us so you know let's pay
attention to that as opposed to the fact
that russia's economy is the size of the
state of new york she one of the things
china's economy is in real tough stretch
right now they have this massive water
crisis in china that is the real deal i
mean it is they have some real problems
and their thing too all the cheap labor
force that they have everyone's moving
up to the middle class in china so they
can't pay people like two pennies an
hour they're having to go and try to
essentially pillage vietnam and other
countries to do this so she has the same
issue that's part of the reason why he
has to go and move on taiwan to go show
up his base get him on rallied say it's
us against the west again yeah and they
have also very little natural resources
very limited ability to farm and produce
food this is why china is trying to turn
a desert into farmland right now this is
the the lengths that they're turning to
they also turned to wet weather
modification trying to alter climates in
order to provide better farming
situations because this is why it's so
important for them to move out of that
landlocked position strategically this
is why they've been building islands
this is why even taiwan is is so
tempting for them because they know they
need to expand their empire if they
don't they're going to be doomed
especially with the population that they
have right now filled with a lot of men
and very little women and
you know the situation in china is like
a perfect storm a perfect recipe of
disaster well
you know to tim to your point about
their aggression even doing things all
the way to hawaii i mean since when did
nine dash line extend to maui right i
mean but that's basically where they are
now they're like hey this is the um
the decoupling is happening what's the
worst case scenario for us though i mean
if china starts expanding and taking
over i know there's economic
consequences so from a really crass
perspective there are a couple things
number one it basically says
if you're if they go and take because
you don't take part of taiwan right it's
an island so either go and take the
whole thing it's a sovereign country
it's not like ukraine where you can
carve out a few miles and say we declare
victory and you know we we stop the
expansion of the eu and all this kind of
stuff
taiwan is different from a couple things
one it's a country where we have drawn a
line is the u.s and said this is an ally
we're immediately signaling we'll do
nothing for japan or anyone else in the
region the other thing too and again
this is very crass but it's you know the
real world the fact that if uh china
were to take taiwan the world
semiconductor market is we are beyond
screwed we have sent everything to
taiwan the us i don't think people
realize if they china will then own
effectively everything and i know that's
that's i'm just being very crass about
it but it's saying that the the west
will never defend an ally just as much
right right right uh cars already hard
to come by computers and it's not just
that we put computer chips in everything
and that's taiwan uh steve bannon was
talking about he said silicon valley
west and that's why you've got u.s
interests desperately trying to pump
government money into american factories
to produce chips silicon chips
semiconductors etc because we know
what's coming and i i i appreciate the
effort but it also kind of feels like
their their quick and desperate moves
into funding american manufacturing in
this you know space while a good thing
just signals we expect taiwan to fall to
china
it's a matter of when not if yeah that's
what china says china officially stated
on the record it's not when we invade
taiwan it's it's no no it's not if we
were sorry sorry yeah yeah it's not if
we invade taiwan it's one let's talk
about how uh
our unfortunate democrat leadership is
impacting us domestically you know
thanks joe biden for your press
conference talking about how you're
doing really really well meanwhile in
this story from yahoo finance la freight
train looting out of control as thieves
worsen supply chain bottlenecks have you
guys seen these photographs out of l.a
or these videos dude the train stops to
unload and like 50 guys jump on with
bolt cutters snap it open start throwing
tvs out people are just loading up
there's boxes everywhere i was i saw one
report where they were like are you
wondering where your amazon delivery
went perhaps it was lost in an la
freight yard and i'm just like watching
a video there's people filming them do
it this is what's happening on the
ground in this country and you see this
stuff i gotta tell you with a trucker
shortage with a labor shortage with the
airlines freaking out canceling flights
every single month for some new problem
you know ukraine war with russia might
be the least of our worries when you
don't have truckers to bring you food
when your goods being shipped by train
are being looted and and your supplies
being destroyed
well we're going to go local i i gotta
say but just really i just want to make
a point china has bullet trains we have
this
[Laughter]
this is true if you guys have i take the
amtrak up to new york every week forget
her and i i get on that i'm like man
this is it's basically like the the joe
biden of trains getting on amtrak
but one of the things if if you go to
the press conference thing just going
back to
brandon for a moment here it was so bad
when he's trying to explain inflation he
was trying to say the reason for
inflation is because of the supply chain
crisis so he's blaming one crisis that
essentially he's allowing to happen
based on another crisis that he's
allowing to happen and it's just the
swirl but this i tell you this story
they were showing some images of the
essentially the yards where it's just
all the empty packages where they've
gone through and ripped everything
there's like you know this entire field
uh look at these photos yeah look at
this pull the stuff up wow this is
absolutely insane i can't believe it's
just looks like l.a the train's going to
derail by hitting cardboard yeah that's
concerning either need armed guards at
this point whether they're human or
robot or turrets or whatever or
bullet trains like you're saying super
fast trains that are enclosed
inside ian calling for auto defense
guys this is how skynet started as you
laugh and the next thing you know
yeah i mean they used to have armed like
a guy would sit on the stage coach with
his shotgun making sure you know what
they didn't get jumped as they were
riding in the 1800s but now we've become
so complacent that we were like hey i
can walk around without looking both
ways
the world's really not that safe have
you ever read or seen judge dredd yeah
yeah i don't know if i want to live in
that world where it's like the trains
are late like you know there's just
layers of auto defense turrets with gun
sights pointing at you as you walk past
me either so let's build magnet mag rail
uh trains
yeah maglev trains that are enclosed
that will also serve as a problem yeah
without turrets turretless or we just
have elon musk to build a bunch of his
tunnels yes yeah but it's basically a
traffic jam it's a synergistic uh
company model because not only do you
build the tunnels underground then you
can build the high-speed rail in the
tunnels and then we do it on mars for
instance where he's colonizing i think
we're going local you know one thing
that we've we've been focusing on is
we've got our own garden we've got
chickens we love our chickens they're
silly little things they lay eggs all
the time and so uh we had a homesteader
on the show a while back talking about
how you know if you even get one or two
percent of of your food source from your
own production you're doing really
really well and when you look at this
stuff it's not an issue of prepping it's
an issue of let me just say if if you
are someone who who has watched joe
biden speak
you probably have already started
prepping
if you're someone who isn't and you're
only watching cnn i need not warn you
about why you should have some emergency
food or you should learn to farm or or
garden or get some animals you need only
watch joe biden speak if you watch that
man speak just like literally don't
watch a clip watch like a full thing of
him talking and you still think he is
doing a good job and we're going to be
fine then by all means you do as you
please but i think the average person
who has not listened to the man who
doesn't know that he said once shrunk it
on a shop at a pressure
once they see that they're going to be
like
how many beans can i buy in one trip to
walmart because that man is terrifying
me not only that if you watch joe biden
tonight you don't already own a firearm
i bet tomorrow's going to be about it
loud and guns it's going to be you know
record lines out the door be like back
during covid i wonder if we can track
that actually because i i don't dis i
agree yeah i think i think people are
gonna go buy guns right if this were
like a militant despotism and we had a
leader like that i was gonna ask like
what would happen to them because right
now we kind of have a decentralized
system the united states is pretty
self-sufficient you know we don't really
need a president to get the job done of
course the military needs a leader but
in a country where that's like autocrat
like libya with gaddafi if if someone
like that got into power that was like
not there what would happen they just
they just haven't completely murdered
instantly and the new president would
take over and but we we live in a place
where it's not so drastic that that guy
is the president doesn't have to be like
a power monster it can be kind of almost
not there it's good when we have
civilian leadership of our armed forces
and the idea is we have our generals but
then we elect a civilian leader who can
then check them and bring some
accountability the problem is when you
have an old man in a wheelchair with a
blanket on his lap pushed into a sun
room and he falls asleep and goes
there's no one keeping any of these
forces in check or organizing them or
even having a plan for what we're doing
because when you guys are then you guys
are like 25th amendment and kamala
harris lol i'm also like no no obvio so
what would happen a go a general would
take control
of our country
let me ask you something
honest question what would you what
would you prefer
all of this in la or kamala harris
locking all of these people up you know
and many innocent people along with it
right this is the challenge
some people might say you know kamala
harris is a brutal dictator type person
who kept people in prison to use slave
labor to fight wildfires actually they
actually for a dollar an hour because
these people were my understanding is
that they were eligible for parole and
she was like no we need the cheap labor
to fight wildfires which is basically in
my opinion slavery and you could have
that and it will mean your train tracks
are clean but i do not like the idea of
empowering someone as evil as that woman
and so it's like then what do we get
sleepy joe asleep on the job and
everything starts falling apart it's
like switching a rock and a hard place
so one thing going back to the bernie
reference um we brought up earlier which
during the campaign i'd always kind of
make that joke and i put out a meme a
few times and here's like nancy and
kamala propping them up and you know
here's a antifa flag in the background
and white house burning and all that
i assumed when biden came in to be
weakened at bernie's but it would be
essentially the hardcore libs that were
propping them up here's the thing i
don't think anybody's holding him up i
don't even think ronclain or jennifer
saki or susan spine susan who's hiding
out there in kellyanne's old office i
don't think any to me i would rather go
against the hardcore lefty who at least
we knew
look we hate their policies but we know
what direction they're going we know how
to how to fight them we can challenge
them on certain points not saying that i
want to cede any of these things to
these people i'd rather have someone
who's a lefty where at least we can go
and combat them as opposed to someone
who's quite frankly incompetent i would
rather have no government so we could
actually live our lives free and
prosperously in a way where we don't
have centralization and control of our
basic human activities that are
absolutely destroyed by these plutocrats
and and fat cats but again but but you
know i'll push back a little bit there's
got to be some cooperation there's got
to be some governance it doesn't i don't
mean yeah and i would lost or our cop
was going to tell you can't do things i
just mean
the more you increase freedom you also
increase risks of course and
i'm actually cool with a substantial
amount of risk but i think people should
consider that it would be more like the
wild west yeah not all bad you know more
freedom no one's going to bug you when
you want to be on your property minding
your own business
but you might get bugged by some bad
people who will be more like more likely
to be unchecked yeah i would argue i
would argue that there would be less
harm uh when it when people get to
figure it out themselves but that's just
my perspective but uh just going on on
topic here again i would be sweating
bullets if i was living in a major city
uh the situation financially is getting
worse it's only going to get worse this
is a slow and deliberate destruction of
this country and what we're seeing on
the railroads is just one symptom of it
this symptom is just a byproduct of this
system crashing financially it's only
going to get worse here the larger
financial ramifications of the lockdowns
the restrictions the mandates we're
still going to feel them and they
haven't been fully even transitioned
into our current state that we're in
right now financial markets take a while
to actually react to certain moves by
governments and i think
it's fair to say especially with how
much we have been indebted with how much
we've been printing that financially the
situation will only get worse here in
the united states and we're going to
have more situations like we're seeing
at the railroads unfold in many
different ways all throughout this
country i always want to point out that
those images i showed i went on google
and i typed in la trains and that was it
wow when you google search la and trains
this is what you see
no
subways you know no no no um sub
stations no smiling people waving with
their kids boarding a train and seeing
their their you know there's there's no
uh husband seeing his wife off as he
boards no it's this all of the images
except for here oh here's a pretty one
look at that beautiful the coaster the
coaster
on the uh uh the the amtrak and then
everything around it is just decay and
ruin i took that trip once it was it's
very nice oh yeah that's right
you go from la to san diego oh okay the
scary thing is that my prediction is
that gavin newsom is the dumb nominee in
2024. yeah and that is so folks or
whitmore whitmer yeah well there was
there was an article once that uh and
it's not just one article but they say
that california is what the united
states will be five years later so that
what happens in california affects the
rest of the country five years on
i hope not
i think with the uh the pushback we're
seeing thanks to the internet that's
gonna play a big role in people waking
up and paying attention we're seeing um
hey getter for instance an opportunity
for people to bypass the censorship and
maintain these values and ideas and
share them if we didn't have that and
people were only able to see this
mainstream narrative then yeah the us
would become california and we would all
live in squalor and destruction so long
as we keep resisting and fighting for
free speech and our ability to share
ideas we're going to hold that off which
brings me to let's talk about gutter and
i'll start with this one we got joe
rogan six days ago the reason i think
this this story is a great way to kick
off the getter uh conversation is that
joe rogan with his co in his
conversation with dr malone helped boost
a lot a lot of the the user numbers on
on getter or should say convince a lot
of people to sign up but then we ended
up with this joe rogan mocks getter less
than a month after joining i don't know
how to get off miss rogan complained the
site artificially bloats follower counts
by including a person's twitter
following on their profile
i think you guys are working on this and
my immediate response is you know not to
make it in softball to begin with but
i mean you're a relatively new social
media platform you're growing really
quickly and you've got to deal with you
know the bumps in the road along the way
to for for joe to be like i don't know
how to get off as if he wants to quit
already it's like yo man give the
platform a chance right well a couple
things here look number one you know joe
if you're watching thank you very much
uh
very appreciative for your joining we've
had uh as you correctly pointed out uh
tim the the dr malone surge uh that's
really helped and we've grown by almost
1.5 million people over the last two and
a half weeks uh so up to about four and
a half million people now that's a 50
increase literally in a little over two
weeks which is massive and good news is
too is that nothing crashed everything
we were always ready in case president
trump came on board but but look go to
the rogan point for a minute just in
case anyone's not on getter obviously ge
ttr in the apple store and google play
just shameless plug but uh what we had
is
we've in about two weeks maybe about
three weeks one of the features we'll
have on getters when you post on getter
you can have the option to then have
that uh post populate on twitter as well
some of the folks the front end of the
house essentially on the engineering
side got ahead of the back end of the
house and they put that out there so
here are the combined follows or how
many people i have and look so just to
clarify make sure i'll get this right he
said you post on twitter it'll appear on
get or is it about post on getter it'll
appear on twitter so one thing just i'm
sorry sometimes i no i think that was my
mistake and so when you start your
account with getter you have the option
of importing in all of your tweets which
is a very cool feature because what
people don't realize that's your
intellectual property you own that
because otherwise if the platforms own
it then they would be liable for
everything that you're writing and
posting on there so we allow people it's
kind of a cool feature like wait all my
tweets are now showing up in my getter
timeline then your history whether it be
your post your memes your recordings
whatever come with
we went and again what we'll have
shortly then for going forward you post
on getter it'll appear on twitter and
then someone never really needs to go to
twitter again the only reason i ever
hear back from people is why they don't
quit twitter is well i have followers
there i have a message i want to go and
get this out so people don't want to
lose that so the spirit of that but
here's where we screwed up as a platform
i'll be on the level when we screw up on
summer don't get something right that
the front end the the user experience
side posted here are the total followers
we've now fixed it so it says here are
the people you're following you're your
getter followers here your total which
is both twitter and getter but the fact
that we allowed that to to go and happen
first as opposed to waiting to the back
end what it did it was it was unforced
error it's a small thing but you know
you just got to own it and say uh hey
here's what we're trying to do uh get it
corrected and then move ahead i want to
talk to you
about some specific individuals uh
notably nick fuentes where a lot of
people are concerned about for being
banned but before we get into that i
think there's some important context and
so we will talk about that in about five
or so minutes but i want to ask you
about your your uh terms of service your
community guidelines and all that
and you know i've pulled up the getter
terms and we've looked at some of it
it's there's a lot of them but i'll i'll
i'll ask you outright and you can answer
as i read through this do you have the
same or similar policies as these other
big
tech platforms like like twitter do you
ban hate speech do you ban you know um
do do you ban wrong think like if
someone has a political opinion that
doesn't fly
so let me go and take them in order
because i think it's important for
people who wonder and say what's the
difference here so again our vision with
getter what we do this is the free
speech platform this is where we make
sure that people who can go and actually
express their political opinion without
getting censored or shadow banned or
algorithmed out of existence simply
because of what they're saying
politically so you take a look at some
of the some of the guests who've been on
this show take a look at steve bannon
take a look at alex jones take a look at
i know dr malone um dr malone hasn't
been on has he yeah not yet hopefully
okay we'll talk about that for the show
uh but you look at some of the people
who even if uh look at james o'keefe
who's just here a couple days ago look
at project veritas people who now have
voices it getter that were kicked off by
twitter terms of service for most of
most all the platforms doesn't matter if
you're in the challenger platforms like
us or
some of the other challengers or from
big tech the reason why terms of service
for many folks look so similar is
because it's effectively your contract
and there's a difference though between
the terms of service and your community
guidelines one of the things where we've
come under some and so our terms of
service very clearly spell out and it's
it's on the both on the website through
here but it says for example that
without limitation we may but do not
commit to
um
is we
fo our attention to offensive uh obscene
lewd filthy pornographic violent
harassing threatening abusive illegal
otherwise objectional inappropriate
content that's within obviously things
like
child abuse or beheading or different
things like that the terms of service
because since it's legal terms if
someone this is your contract with
someone for signing up that's why terms
of service are is going to be written in
that manner where we are in working to
improve is a platform is it's a post and
we're working on this right now we hope
to have it soon i don't know the exact
timeline more specific community
guidelines so it's even clearer for
people okay you guys say that you're the
free speech platform we realize okay
that somebody who's been kicked off
these other platforms they can come
express themselves politically and no
one's going to go and vote them off the
island for talking about covet or voting
issues or climate change there's not
committed warning labels but give us a
little more granularity and that's one
of the things we've heard from people
who are working to put that together to
publish so we we asked this similarly of
rumble uh it's uh it says right here
ghetto holds freedom of speech as its
core value and does not wish to censor
your opinions nonetheless you may not
post on or transmit through the service
any unlawful harmful threatening abusive
harassing defamatory libelous and decent
vulgar obscene sexually explicit
pornographic profane hateful racially
ethnically or otherwise objectionable
material of any kind including any
material that encourages conduct that
would constitute a criminal offense give
rise to civil liability or otherwise
violate any law rule or regulation
of that of the laws applicable to you or
applicable in the country in which the
material is posted so i'm curious
because
the idea of banning
hateful content i mean that's
editorially defined and i do want to
make sure we say as we go into this
getter clearly is going to allow more
speech than these other platforms but
i'm wondering why it is that uh
getter has the same language we said
that you outright say you cannot be you
know hateful racially or ethnically or
or obscene and we see that same language
on all the other big tech silicon valley
platforms so a couple of things here
because
again keep in mind that for most
countries especially in the u.s your
free speech rights for the most part
extend up until the point where they
infringe on someone else's rights if
we're going to have a platform where we
allow people to come on and keep it very
real politically to keep it very
politically incorrect if that's where
they want to be there have to be some
standards in place to make sure that
people don't think that it's a
threatening or potentially illegal
environment so they're with so they're
but hateful but hold on but there's but
you notice we do not use hate speech
which is a phrase that p the left has
taken over and they and then it's like
who defines it as uh is hate speech for
example but here's one of the things
we're not gonna allow to happen uh on
getter and this is something where i get
a lot of pushback from people uh but
they've said or we've said excuse me
that we're not gonna allow racial or
religious epithets on the platform i
have not had one person who's come to me
yet and said you know what if only i
could use the blank word uh then it
would be an okay platform you know the
fact that i like getter except i can't
use the blank word it's just you have to
go and have you're not going to make
every single person happy but we have to
have a platform especially being global
the us is about 57 right now of our
overall base it's a global platform we
have to make sure that people regardless
of your religious or your um uh racial
background that you feel welcome on the
platform well i got a question i really
want to ask who gets to decide what is
obscene because some people would say
ian's obscene hey or i'm not denying
who decides what is obscene is there any
oversight or transparency when it comes
to banning people or shadow banning
people do you guys shadow band as well
that's another question that people are
asking so taking it in reverse order no
shadow banning no algorithming one the
thing people realize with getter is
everything's in the linear time frame so
you do not have remember that's kind of
the old twitter before they changed up
and got the algorithm advanced to where
they went and you know i'll give you an
example of an algorithm dinesh d'souza
who's on gutter and who he brings the
heat on social media in my opinion i
think the guy's great
i i didn't even know that he effectively
didn't know that he was on twitter
because i never see any of his content
he gets on getter and you know man the
guy's like every other post he's pretty
prolific because there was the shadow
banning prior to being ceo of getter i
could literally do the the proverbial
coffee and i'd get 2 000 retweets now i
can have an actual legit you know i'll
take one of my getter posts and put them
over on twitter i'll get like 30 people
retweeting just hey you guys want ceo no
shadow banning or anything in fact one
of the things i've made very clear as a
ceo everybody gets treated the same it
doesn't matter if you're on the left on
the right something look people tell me
i'm number one in a not very positive
way all the time that's that's part of
the part of the drill you come on there
you want to go and speak your opinion
great you can go and have that so
there's no shadow banning or
algorithming of of any sense yeah but
but so to your next point then about who
decides this so we work with two parts
is how our moderation platform works
first of all we have so it's two parts
both an ai component artificial
intelligence as well as human moderators
there are a number of key features it's
you know like 44 or so different
categories of things say for like a
full-on pornography or something that's
a beheading um
you know things are just certain words
for example uh that will get stopped
immediately from getting posted that's
what they call the api so they can go
before it so it's not like it goes
somewhere and it gets screened literally
you can't even do it from the api from
the platform
so those things get blocked certain
things are in the category of and again
it's it's got to be pretty darn strong
for to get uh for it to get blocked but
then things are say between a you know
five on the scale to nine on the scale
then go to human moderators to go and
review and what we have with so the all
the human moderators who are part of
getter number one they go through pretty
extensive background check so usually
before someone gets onboarded uh i want
to say it's upwards of at least two or
three weeks of going through do a
background check to make sure they're
not going to be bringing some aspect of
a political bias to it
then are these americans or foreign
workers uh all the above so there are
people because keep in mind i mean we
have people who are monitoring 14
languages right now uh so i'll tell you
that there's you know you're only going
to find so many people in the us are
monitoring japanese for example so we
have people you know but there'll be a
lot of people in south australia and new
zealand who might be monitoring you know
japanese or even monitoring mandarin or
arabic though so you know i think it's i
think it's 40 it might be 15 languages
now but the other thing too is going
through and then certain things the
moderators might not know uh they might
not uh so in addition to the the
background check uh obviously then we do
the spot checks and making sure where
things are certain things where they're
gonna be questions and i've had you know
i've had things that are frivolous they
get elevated up to our executive board
uh then we have a
six-person team that they go both
combination of kind of the user
interface folks as well as the legal
people who kind of look through it where
something has to get we decide okay
what's our posture going to be certain
things then get brought to my attention
i'll tell you some of the things have
been frivolous like on the first day one
of the moderation people came running up
and you know jason jason someone just
posted the picture of hunter biden with
the feather boa and the tidy whities you
know what do we say and of course my
answer on that is look i'm never going
to tell the son of the president united
states what he can and can't wear
in his pictures and i'm going to defend
his freedom to wear that feather boa
that's frivolous i'll tell you something
that's not frivolous is after the uh
afghanistan uh airport bombing kabul
where there were images that were posted
of actual people blowing up like pretty
is there newsworthiness to that as much
as it's been so here is so going through
that because this is this is like this
is the type of decision that we have to
sit down and make is that
we are such an anti-terrorism
uh
anti-authoritarian regime you can't go
and sweep stuff under the rug and look a
lot of our people are on board saying
france and germany have dealt with the
terrorist bombings firsthand so we we
made the decision you cannot show the
act of killing someone so you couldn't
actually show
and i'm not trying to i'm just being
very direct you can't show the act of
somebody blowing to pieces but you can
show what the the carnage is afterwards
i literally went through this
last night with our director of
moderation where one of our verified
users showed somebody driving who was
being shot in somewhere in the middle
east so it's actually the act of
shooting the person and while in the
single take they went up and opened the
door and pulled out essentially a dead
family with the kids so in that context
said look because it's showing the act
of killing them we can't show that but
if it's showing afterwards hey here's
what happens on attack that the people
are dead that's that's where we decide
to draw the draw the line it's tough
because i totally understand why people
would be like we don't want that on our
platform but there's a very important
newsworthiness that wouldn't a a filter
make you know be better maybe some kind
of like you know you don't see it unless
you opt in and click unless you decide
to follow those people like shouldn't
people have the choice to say i want to
follow this
cover i don't want to derail from the
point i'm making the point i'm making is
in this world if a serious moment
happens let's say we saw what happened
with aaron danielson a trump supporter
was walking down the street an antifa
guy put two in his chest
as much as it's a gruesome act we i i
think people need to see you know the
newsworthiness of this this happened in
this country and if you restrict that
people won't believe it you you could go
to someone and say did you know that a
far left antifa guy killed the dude and
they'll be like show me the video i
can't get her banned would you ban the
george floyd video
i would not ban the the george floyd
video but that's a video of someone
dying
but it's the
with the george that's a good question
on the george floyd video
it's
the
the george floyd video was different for
the fact that it
was a much longer process when he's on
the ground he's choking and correct my
phone wrong but he didn't die until
shortly thereafter no he died in the
ground did he did he get down there in
the ground yeah on the ground okay
so you guys can ban it or keep it
so that's a thing i would need to i
would need to watch that video again to
go and see it but if it's my when i was
thinking through i thought that he died
shortly thereafter uh but if it's the
actual act of him dying then the moment
i think it's a little bit different when
someone's exploding you know that's the
moment when they're dying as opposed to
here's the process of him slowly having
the oxygen what about the aaron
danielson thing
there's a video you could you can't
really see it perfectly but you can see
him walk up and he yells we got him here
and then you hear bang bang and then the
guy you see the gas go off the explosion
happens when the tank like ruptures and
a trump supporter he's dead when
when i talk to people about what's going
on in the united states with rioting and
violence it's really easy to explain to
them you know the fringe right element
or ultra traditionalists or whatever
that they do crazy things ramming cars
or shooting people but trying to find
evidence of antifa when it's covered up
by the media and they say it's lying is
very difficult
so if if we're trying to go on social
media if someone like andy no is on the
ground and he films this you guys would
ban it
uh if it's again we're
it's tough to do the 100 and again we're
gonna we'll get some things wrong and
we're not always going to get it right
every time we're continually reviewing
it uh and that's where
when you see it you'll know but again if
it's when you take like you know what
happened to andy for example and
obviously he was beaten and uh he wasn't
killed was right yeah thankfully yeah
exactly uh obviously but they're you
know what happened with andy that's or
if andy was in position of filming what
happened to andy for example
if they took his life in the street
you'd ban people from being able to see
them doing it
uh our posture is that we would show the
the aftermath but the moment of where
someone's life is being taken uh the
floyd
the floyd one becomes a little bit more
difficult where a lot of
uh even a lot of the and again we're not
the big news outlets but we're a
newsletter would show is here's part of
the struggle that was happening that
might show that actual moment
so that's maybe to to clarify and again
that's why it's tough to even say here's
the broad generalization because it's
right now with our kind of our our
our
north star so to speak in dealing with
this is that that moment where someone's
life is being taken
that should not be shown but obviously
here is the the carnage in the aftermath
of what happened uh and again here's the
thing these are um the tough decisions
you have to make when you're running a
platform because at a certain point you
have to decide that's why i said not
everyone's gonna agree with you on every
single time
you in order to defend
our mission of having the political free
speech and allowing people to go way
further than rely and not be and not
have the political discrimination
exercise against them there has to be
that certain point where you're looking
saying here's the line and that's tough
well i personally i disagree with that
policy but i respect you standing firm
and saying that's your policy and people
who are listening can decide for
themselves if they're you know if that's
a um a deal-breaker or not i certainly
think there's value in the fact that
you're allowed to talk about news
um outside of that context that twitter
doesn't allow that joe rogan would be
able to talk with dr robert malone on
getter so i suppose people just have to
navigate that stuff but let's talk about
this
i got i got to ask you uh about a
specific individual as it pertains to
all these policies you say that people
will not be treated differently but a
lot of people are asking why nick
fuentes was was banned from getter and
what were hearings everybody's saying he
did not break any of your rules
i would disagree on that it's uh the
there was a post that he brought or put
on getter uh that was interpreted from
our position as recruiting people who
are in the white nationalist space and
that's not something when it comes to
one the white nationalist group so we're
going to allow to happen on getter and
look i'm not going to lie
what did he say
he was effectively reaching out and are
there other gripers that are on here
what's how would you define a grouper
uh as a white nationalist but you so you
don't allow white nationalists on getter
well anyone can come on and join the
play except for terrorists we banned
terrorists we don't do not allow
terrorists so we've gone through and
found the the twitter handles and other
things for you know the ayatollah or uh
hamas or hezbollah or some of these
other folks and block those accounts on
getter so they can't go and create it
obviously someone could try to work
around and find it but if we find that
we're gonna go and kick it off uh but if
you're the way that we look at if you're
part of a group that the only reason for
existing uh is to go and try to cause uh
uh harm uh to other people that's gonna
make this an environment that's gonna go
and scare people and make them not feel
safe just really quickly
i just wanna know what specific term of
service was that a violation
of uh that would go into or i would say
that many people would be concerned that
if you're turning uh getter effectively
into the uh okay
what's the specific term or service that
he violated
with that post uh so that that would go
into uh as we talk about
uh a white nationalist group you talk
about what that impact is gonna be for
say people of different races or
religions
so that because the presence of a white
nationalist would be negative to another
group you've banned him
uh i i would describe it differently i
would say from the fact that you're
trying to then recruit for one of these
organizations uh so black lives matter's
band uh i would say if you if you went
on there and said that say any group
that's viewed is uh is existing only to
go and hate on people who are uh of a
different uh race or religion and you
try to turn uh get her into a
recruitment zone then you would kick it
off as well it seems a bit of a stretch
look uh for obvious reasons i'm no fan
of any of these white nationalists you
know especially the stuff my family has
dealt with and then i got to deal with
the racist woke people who accuse me of
just all the stupidest trash
it's laughable
but there's there's the issue here is
posting on getter saying you know are
there any other grapers doesn't seem
like he was targeting offending
attacking or recruiting it just was like
hey who's in the house
and it and it seems to me that you
you you guys probably banned him for a
pr issue you don't want to i i and this
is my opinion correct me if i'm wrong
but it seems to me that you're worried
that you'll get kicked out of the play
store that you'll get negative
ramifications from uh from big tech in
silicon valley and the only real reason
to get rid of them was the threat from
the establishment media
you know no i i'd push back on that i
mean if that was the case that would be
hiding under the the covers with the
flashlight saying what are people saying
about covid what are people saying but
so i
what you just described to us would mean
that you have to anyone who's woke is
banned because they they routinely their
their ideology specifically calls out
the idea of whiteness they're calling
out white as a as like a negative thing
and so if someone goes on getter and
says how many you know who here is a
black lives matter supporter you would
ban them
i would say if anyone is going out there
obviously the
a little bit of difference on some of
the blm i think there are people are
participating uh saying some of the
march but people are going out there
look if you're saying that you're part
of a group and the only reason for being
a part of the group is to hate on
someone who uh is of a different race or
religion uh we're not going to allow it
to become a recruiting zone
there there are a lot of left-wing
groups that specifically do that
diversity equity inclusion wokeness
critical race theory
so are you well there's but there's
there's a difference when you talk about
some of the uh look and we have uh libs
and lefties and different people on the
platform but it's different between
going on there and saying
i support some liberal ideology it was
another saying i'm going to go if you
had somebody's on there saying uh uh
look they want to be a part of a group
that their only mission was to go and
try to take down white people or take
down people with some other race or
religion then we'd kick them off
so i mean
these writers these uh so like robin
d'angelo's band from ghetto uh i don't
know robin so so she she you know she
writes about whiteness and and
criticizes whiteness and so er max candy
he's banned from getter i i would have
to see with the right map and other
people those those two names that i
don't know but again so
candy has specifically called for racial
discrimination you'd ban him for that
like in his book he actually says the
the solution to past discrimination is
present discrimination the solution to
present discrimination is future
discrimination so so if he signed up
you'd be like you're gone
if it was someone and again i'd want to
see the specific example to see how
that's written but the way that you
described it on that then we would not
allow someone like that on the platform
it sounds like you're actually way more
strict than twitter there well no i'd i
would disagree and say that what twitter
is trying so here's the difference
there's a massive difference here
when we set out with the platform and we
have our our vision of what we're trying
to do here make sure people go and
express their opinions and not get
kicked off and say that one ideology is
accepted but another ideology for
example is not accepted twitter looks
and says we want to form the world in a
certain viewpoint we want to have people
go in this certain direction that's not
what we're trying to do but but the one
thing to make sure is that we have to
make sure that people feel safe to be
able to come on the platform and if they
feel that that and again this isn't a
say you disagree on something twitter's
logically that's twitter's viewpoint i
verbatim what jack dorsey told me we
have to make sure it's safe for people
and he said the reason they have the
misgendering policy is because trans
people feel unsafe by people questioning
trans uh transgender ideology or or or
transgender dysphoria
it's like they're saying the same thing
no because i think it's i think it's
totally different because what they're
saying is they're going into places say
like in the public policy space and
they're saying that our
viewpoint is allowed but another
viewpoint is not but when you're going
into a place and again whether you're
going in there and
it's effectively attacking another group
uh or if you're representing a group
that is about attacking people we're not
gonna allow that so if someone will say
white people are inferior or white
people are crackers would you ban them
for that speech
i said white people are inferior or
white people are crackers or not evil
evil white people are evil oh yeah yeah
no if yeah if you went and said yes if
you once said something like uh yes like
to a particular group then we would take
that post down depending on the severity
of the post that was there depend if the
user has their account suspended so what
about someone like uh uh abigail
schreier is that her name she wrote the
book on
transgender children
would she be allowed to be on the
platform talking about gender dysphoria
and children
so on
so again not familiar with that that
particular author but there's a
difference between there's difference
between someone being an idiot and being
wrong and someone who's actively
representing uh
actively making the platform unsafe for
someone else to be on so for example
uh someone going on there saying hey
here's my idiotic left to center woke
teaching for example okay but if they're
going out and saying that
essentially suggesting harm uh uh
physical harm or physical threat on
another community then you can't allow
that well how do you so so if you have
someone uh like like youtube uh twitter
instagram they have these policies on
protecting the trans community
if someone on getter
said something like children should not
be allowed to undergo
gender
reassignment that doctors who are giving
them these chemicals are are wrong and
all of these medical treatments should
be taken away from these children and
their parents should be arrested would
that be a lot on the platform
uh i have uh short answers the way that
you've described it yes that would be
along the platform correct so it's it
the difficult thing for me is you know i
had that conversation with jack dorsey i
referenced it it gets referenced a lot
it sounds the exact exact same
conversation the difference being
jack says in our view of the world what
we prioritize we've decided to keep the
platform safe and ban these people and
it just sounds like you have a different
view of what you think is going to be
safe or not safe so you probably as a
more conservative leading individual
when i bring up that stuff about trans
kids you're like oh we'd allow that well
jack dorsey would ban that but then when
it comes to someone like nick fuentes
you're like oh we're going to ban that
twitter also twitter also man but again
i'm going to push back on this and i'm
going to say that look and i think that
the questions we guys are bringing up
are very fair and look i get
trust me i get the questions all day
long but here is i think there's a
complete different because our
philosophy is we want to have a place
where people can come and bring their
their hottest takes whether they want to
take whether it be politically incorrect
whether it be again come from the left
or the right where they don't have to
worry about someone coming in
editorializing and saying well this is
my position this is how i view the world
uh with regard to uh you know if this is
whether it be you know again you know i
would use like covet or voting or
whatever the case or like if you want to
come and talk about you know kind of pro
wochism type stuff or left to center we
do not look at it and say we want this
opinions but we don't want that opinion
that's that's the difference between us
and big tech big tech is coming in
whether it be twitter facebook everyone
else they're putting up the warnings
they're then editorializing it is not
not our place to go and editorialize and
say that this person's political
viewpoint is right and this person is
wrong unless it unless it goes against
diversity inclusivity and equity but
there's hold on i don't think that's a
fair fair description because
when so let's take the immigration
debate for example there are in there
countless people have been kicked off
and take a look what's happening in
france right now i think part of the
reason even why eric zemor who's a
conservative candidate who's running for
president in france has joined getter
because he's what he's talking about is
are the problems caused by migration
other things that are happening
and he would get suspended or kicked off
by saying half of that stuff on twitter
because they don't want you to talk
about the reality of say immigration the
problems that are that are caused or
even just and again whether it's legal
or illegal or what's going on
getter you're gonna be able to go and
express yourself and talk about these
issues now if you want to
take into the next step about i want to
cause harm to somebody where could then
but what does that mean harm
if if you went and well i mean obviously
we have a number of different categories
in there if you went said that
you know everyone from um you know
everyone who has the skin color is bad
um i i think that uh we would go and
remove that post
so that's i mean that's that's very much
look uh i'll i'll stress it again
obviously i think
very few people in the united states
like racism uh there was a really great
point i mean there are races in this
country are going to be wrong and there
was a really great point made on tucker
carlson's show where one of his guests
he brought a leftist a lefty person who
said tucker would you allow someone to
come on here and make racist comments
and tucker was like i wouldn't exactly
and that's your platform and your right
to do so that i get because i don't i
don't like any of that stuff i just feel
like
it is
getter along with any one of these other
platforms has decided this is the only
acceptable worldview you are not allowed
to do these things on our platform
you know period and so that that's the
big issue if you say it's about free
speech then often what we've brought up
is you know on this show and many
anarchists have said this and many
conservatives then it then the only
speech that should be banned is if it
crosses a legal threshold not an opinion
threshold even if we really despise
those opinions so for instance i despise
white nationalists i think they're
stupid i think and and i really hate the
woke people but there is a real strength
of diversity for talking about the
actual core of diversity of viewpoint
which can come from people around the
world and things like this but as much
as i despise their opinions i think
banning that just leads us down a
slippery slope of authoritarianism and
if conservatives who are creating
alternatives still uphold silicon
valley's world view even if it's a
little bit less in 10 years it will just
keep getting worse so i'm going to
disagree with you um and the reason on
that is
what big tech and silicon valley are
doing
they're trying to push people in a
certain direction and say here's what
in the youtube the climate change we're
joking about it um uh before the show
but it's actually a very serious point
because that is where it's expanded
beyond okay here's uh trump and we're
gonna be mad at him for january 6 or
something that nature or this is you
know causing some kind of you know
sedition or some kind of illegal
activity they're not going into the
public policy space and they're saying
if you agree with our position or all
world view and it might even be that
granular start going to say whether you
know trans or immigration or you know
different issues like that
i just i i agree with you i understand
the point you're making i'm not trying
to be uh rude but i think we're starting
to go in a circle you know what i mean
so okay yeah i just
i i guess your your point and i and i
think it's still a good thing and and i
hate to be you know we have the
opportunity to bring rumble ceo on and
yuan and it becomes this like negative
critical thing but we would never get
this opportunity with zuckerberg or you
know widjiski or whoever the ceo of
twitter is and so that's one thing i
think is important to point out we
should be careful about you know being
overly critical and potentially damaging
to opportunities if if getter still has
the same rules or similar rules to
twitter in this regard but doesn't
editorialize political opinion in regard
to policy and stuff
then i'd rather use getter and i think
it's a good thing that being said i
think in the bigger picture of
the bigger picture
we need alternatives and
decentralization intact in social media
space that
doesn't make ethical decisions for what
people are allowed to say
you know in your view you think it's
unsafe for people if someone comes on
and doesn't like their skin color
i don't know if unsafe is the right word
i don't know if i would agree with that
if someone says bad things about someone
of a race i don't like those people i
think they're awful um i wouldn't want
to associate with them and i would vote
against them and i would encourage my
friends to vote against them if they
want to bring those policies up but i
fear
a society where
we have homogenized you know uh we we we
are increasingly homogenizing the moral
pathway so
let me take a slightly different take on
that uh and again as i mentioned earlier
we have global platform about half of
the u.s a little more than half outside
one of the things were part of the
reason why some of the alternative the
challenger platform so to speak have
never taken off is because they've been
viewed as an echo chamber and then
saying that you know this is just a a
white nationalist a playground something
of that nature
if
you actually want to go and have debates
you want to have people that are going
to participate and be in there the
message has to be sent you have to have
the spirit of the platform that you can
come on here and you can have your
unfiltered political take and you can go
and criticize people go and do your
thing but people aren't concerned that
they're going to become harmed by
something that happens from the platform
but you're being harmed like they'll see
a mean thing
no no not a mean thing but i'm saying
because real quickly
um
as we talk about again if we getter was
allowed to become
like i said the okay cupid of the um of
the social media space for for white
nationalists then
then that's going to go and tell people
a massive people that this is not an
actual place for free speech this is
just this is just something for for one
group yeah but then it's in the
algorithm you could choose what you want
to hear who you want to be subscribed to
so if you don't want to see that you
just algorithm subscribe to them and
then my bigger kind of question that's a
little bit more pointed is you know a
lot of people feel let down by big tech
by social media arbitrarily censoring
speech all in the name of safety you're
talking about you know respecting free
speech other than just words and
promises are there any reinsurances that
you could give the people here today
that you won't become like the next
twitter or facebook yeah no that's a
very fair question i'd say a couple of
things you can look at i would say take
a look at right now some of those names
that i pointed out earlier i've taken a
look whether it's dr malone or alex
jones uh or steve bannon or people that
are on the platform and again my goal uh
and right now obviously naomi wolf is
not you know the extreme i'd say like on
the on the left side but we have had
actually a number of feminists from the
uk who've joined the platform because
they um even they've gotten fed up with
some of the big tech our goal as we
expand i want people from the left i
want people from the center i want
people from the right want people all
over one of the things we're doing i
kind of touched on this earlier is we're
in start but we're working on it we
should have done by now again we've only
been around six months but that's not an
excuse because we're always i mean we're
gonna be judge against platforms been
around for a lot longer is start
publishing more of the specific
community guidelines of things so people
understand kind of where those those
areas are but when when every the
mission that everyone on our team has
whether it's on the team whether it's a
moderator everybody
there are two litmus tests if you're
going to be a part of getter
as far as our team on board number one
do you support free speech number two do
you oppose cancel culture and wilkism
those are two things doesn't matter what
country you're in doesn't matter what
your background is those are the two
principles that you're going to be on
board and everybody either you're on
board with that or you're not part of
the platform it's a free country
i'll say up front i really like
competing businesses especially in the
social media sphere but some issues i
basically right away is like without
limitation the ability to ban anyone
that is deemed defensive or
inappropriate i get it any as a private
company i feel like you should be able
to ban anyone at any time whatever when
we talk about free speech and social
networking i believe it's not about the
terms of service because the new you
could quit another guy could come in and
be like well now that's offensive no
that has beanies offensive so
free speech and social networking is
free software code
that's the freedom the ability to pick
it up and make another one
well we're building that i don't think
we should take it away from people who
built their own private one we can build
our public one you can't i can't force
someone to free their software code but
i can't trust like you said there's no
shadow banning i correct i can't trust
that unless i can inspect the code well
part of that uh look part of that
is
so a couple of things here is you start
moving toward uh which again we hope to
be an ipo within a couple of years here
you know we're about six months in about
two years when you start moving toward
uh going into and obviously we want to
be a public company
the comments and the positions are taken
by the leadership ceo other people there
are ramifications if you if you're not
accurate and tell people so if you were
to go out and say that there's no shadow
banding no algorithmic and they find out
that as the ceo you're saying that but
that is happening then there are i mean
you know the the sarbane oxley type
things on crack that would go and uh
that you'd be in real actual trouble so
there is an actual method where if
you're putting out uh untrue statements
then there are real ramifications you
could see how like fauci said i never
said we did gain a function we just
added function to the bat so you could
say we're not shadow banning but be
doing something similar to shadow
banning and people wouldn't know but
also part of that look one that i mean
but look i don't want to put you on the
defensive it's not about what you say
it's that i can't trust you i have to
only trust the code base so and real
quick twitter has claimed over and over
again it's an accident it's an accident
it's an accident they've said we don't
shadow bad and they get caught then they
go and testify before congress
unfortunately ian's right i don't agree
with him on forcing companies to free
their software code you guys built this
proprietary you own it but the reality
is
there's no real way for us to know that
these platforms are being fair and
honest in their algorithms unless they
do release all the code
so
you're right from the aspect that the
transparency from the aspect of what's
going on that's critical if you want to
go and have the the trust and
verification i do think that for some of
the bigger users and people we have on
the platform those are pretty good
signals about how we're judging how
we're treating things i also think that
myself as a ceo the fact that i've gone
into the the proverbial lions den
whether that's sitting down with carrich
care swisher for three hours
or sitting down with uh uh
you know the the tim cass folks for a
couple hours that you have to go there
and say here's what the the spirit is
and here's what we're doing and then you
have to make sure that you go and
everybody on the team goes in the exact
same position if they're not then
they'll get fired they'll get bounced in
a moment and that is uh that is exactly
where right and so one of the things
that we're doing because the terms of
service just be clear on this because
when we first have the terms of service
and we started going through and that
was kind of to your point it was well
what you know this looks legally like
this looks very and again with the
lawyer said i'm not a lawyer but
obviously i spent a lot of money now in
lawyers what they said is that well
because you can't go into uh a court of
law on someone if you have a contract
with someone and just say well here here
are my feelings for example because
they'll say that's bs there's very
specific language is because this is
your contract with someone where we are
going to this is the point i made a
moment ago when we start publishing more
of the community guidelines so people
know within the exact things there uh as
far as certain statements and in uh
what's allowed what's what's not
permitted they'll have a better
understanding of that um we should have
that out there at the beginning there's
also a lot of questions i just want to
ask one more question here before we
wrap here um
there's a lot of people asking about the
money that came into to to build getter
what's stopping it from uh obviously
influencing the platform since i think
it came from one individual from from
china i believe i'm correct and the
second question is what's your strategy
against being influenced by the esg
environmental social governance score
when you when your company does go
public
ah okay so a couple of things there the
uh i will take him in reverse order
again uh i will admit least since we're
a little ways away from the uh the going
public some of some of the details on
that i'm not an expert on i'll just tell
you that i don't have that where i
typically get into more of the battles
is what's going on now where we see
certain countries that are starting to
say you have to go and allow certain
things now obviously we have to make
sure that we are
abiding by say a country's laws so for
example what's permitted uh if it's a
country that we care about and that's
part of it there might be some countries
that that might say hey if you allow
this on the platform then we're not
going to have you here we might say well
we're not changing anything just for you
guys so um obviously you got to take on
kind of the country by country basis um
but some of that with the
the esg part i admittedly uh can't speak
to quite as well so big investment firms
come into companies saying you need to
abide by uh this goal in this role and
we're going to implement this policy and
give you all this institutional money
when you promote this agenda yeah and
we'd tell someone to pound sand i mean
that when you talk about kind of other
things or kind of the spirit even if you
go to our logo uh the getter the torch
with the flame what that represents
that's about bringing likeness to dark
about bringing freedom and democracy to
places where they don't have it so for
example one of the things we want to do
i still fundamentally think uh look i'm
not like it um uh you know i wouldn't
say that i'm i've uh uh rose-colored
glasses on i still think that social
media can be a force for good for
expanding democracy and taking down
authoritarian authoritarian regimes
around the world i would love for people
in china to rise up and take down the
ccp i would love for people to use have
that freedom of expression that thought
because here's the deal
as soon as you start taking away
people's ability to communicate their
ability to speak
you're basically at china and that's
basically where you are or you're in
iran or wherever the case where they do
this let me go you know i see
i do want to answer his other part but
if you want to jump in oh yeah but the
investment money from china i think is
an important question so for that yeah
so but but to the point if someone came
in and said hey we want to go and buy
you guys but you know we're going to
transition you guys into a bunch of
wokesters or something to go pound sand
i mean that's let me go to the funding
because i want to make sure that i take
this this head on there are no questions
so we're back by multiple international
investment firms uh one that's based in
london one that's based in new jersey uh
we have additional people that we're
currently doing rounds of meetings to go
and chat with about additional
investments that are coming in there is
no china money there's no ccp money uh
that's involved in this
and that's one of the things where i
think just quite frankly look when you
search to number one you've got a big
old target on your back everyone's going
to take shots at you this specific name
that's frequently brought up is miles
guo
who is uh here in the us on political
asylum uh he has someone who's a very
strong ally of the company he's someone
who's a
very much a
kindred spirit as far as i mean
literally he took a song
on itunes called take down the ccp to
number one so okay if he hit number one
on itunes with a song called take down
the ccp i'm gonna guess that you
probably don't like the ccp uh now his
great music video by the way as well uh
it is
it is pretty cool um but the uh one of
the firms who's invested in this uh has
a heavy influence from miles's family
foundation uh miles does not have a
direct financial or leadership role
within the company i have a board of
directors with my company i have
shareholders that i am accountable to
that is the structure uh no you know i
get ideas or hear things from miles or
obviously he's very supportive uh and
we're very like-minded i've spent a lot
of time with him talking about taking
down the ccp and kind of our shared
world view on that uh he is not my boss
he is not someone who goes and says this
is what the policy is going to be or not
going to be or that case uh but look
here's the the thing is
when you come in you become a
marketplace disrupter when you come in
not just taking on the big tech but you
go and there are other people who are
saying that
viewed as more in the center
center-right type space or people who
challenge their platforms everyone
starts shooting at you and so people go
and uh obviously there's a lot of things
to put out from other platforms uh
they're just plain false and i think
that uh it's sad if they think that all
of a sudden people are gonna oh i'm not
gonna go together but i'm going to go to
your platform but look this is this is
the nfl
yeah you said what i was going to say
earlier that social media is a great
opportunity to solve this authoritarian
dictatorship crisis on earth i fully
agree with that but the problem i keep
coming up against is that corporations
are inherently authoritarian we have
they're top ending you said you could
fire everybody if they stop agreeing
with you you could
do whatever you want that's true so you
own the contract so so it's like the
process is this is the we the pathway is
the goal so like being authoritarian to
solve authoritarian doesn't that doesn't
rub me the right way i want to get to
super i'm yeah i don't want to apologize
this is a great show i want to get to
the questions from the audience can i
just make one point here
when i was going through that when i
started first chatting with um the
shareholders and people putting getter
together over the this last spring uh
and we chatted i probably spent three or
four months talking to him before i came
back before i left president trump and
came on board uh with getter
and part of things i really want to kick
the tires on some of these questions
because when look if i'm going to go and
put my reputation online and and bring
people onto this and go out and say hey
you need to come together this is the
free speech platform this is the one
platform that can actually take down big
tech this is the platform that can be
the twitter killer you got to kick the
tires you got to make sure that you're
pretty solid and i remember asking a
question during the process to an
interview process when i kind of turned
it around and said if there's an
opportunity here to
enter into a new country where we can
get 10 million new users
or but we're going to have to cow town
some way to the ccp or we could say no
to entering into this country but we can
go and make progress on taking down the
ccp but we miss out on 10 million new
customers where would it be they said a
hundred times out of the hundred take
down the ccp that is that is where
things are and so when you're wondering
about kind of the where we're coming
from but our north star is that's
exactly where it is let me read some of
these questions we got waffle sensei all
right we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
this video wherever you can let people
know to come watch we're going to answer
your super chats the best of our
abilities go to timcast.com for the
uncensored members show which will be up
around 11 or so p.m let's read waffles
sensei says jason can you promise
publicly and in the written policy that
when you are forced to censor content
because your team finds it too egregious
to remain in the platform that you will
that you will offer an easy path to
forgiveness and a limit on the amount of
time you can ban someone
i think that's a great point one of the
things where we have not done an
effective job enough with people is
notifying them for exactly for how long
a suspension will be or what exactly um
and i will say that uh look is the ceo
uh some of that will will come on me of
saying it should have that tightened up
more by now so i will say that the
um make making it clear to someone
here's how long the suspension will be
can it was that was mainly about the the
duration
is that well so what they're what
they're asking for is a path of
forgiveness right with twitter if you
break the rules you get a life sentence
and so one of the things that dorsey had
talked about in the past that he never
implemented was there would always be a
time limit that you could post the most
egregious thing and they wouldn't boot
you permanently from the platform it
might just be like a year suspension or
two years or three or there would be
some path to redemption so you can come
back on the platform so i think i think
this is a great question i would say
that there i say that for many cases
there should be a path of forgiveness uh
now some there's not going to be so for
example if you go put up a uh and again
we could say here and do the the back
and forth on which examples but say for
example like you post child porn or
something like that okay you're never
coming back but i think that there are
um there are cases where there should be
a path of forgiveness i think that's an
insightful question and when we post our
community guidelines in greater detail
uh we will have a pathway back to
forgiveness uh more articulately fleshed
out but i think that's actually a really
smart point you know i'm a big fan of
banning accounts instead of individuals
that way if they violate it with one
account and they make a new account
that's not violating the terms then you
don't ban it it's otherwise it feels
like a witch hunt that's how i run it
anyway
so let me go and push back on that a
little bit sometimes it's not all the
way so say for example if you had um uh
the ayatollah for example so the
ayatollah says okay we're banning you
know at uh i hate israel or whatever the
i told his account is uh but then he
pops in as uh you know uh you know steve
from iran and he keeps you know spouting
off the same nonsense
that's like a quick example of where
it's not always quite that easy if it's
the same nonsense you keep banning it
but if it comes on with an innocuous
channel and is like hey i'm back sorry
you know i'm not going to make that
mistake again
that's kind of like for me the on-ramp
to reject i think
i think that
i i think that more of what that uh the
the user question that just post on the
on the super chat i think is more
accurate and i think that's uh as i'm
thinking through that here that's i
think that's a smart point
the smart idea
i'm just looking through the the super
chats trying to make sure i can find
good questions a lot of the super chats
people are asking about nick fuentes and
i and and a lot of them we we addressed
i i am going to bring him back up in
other contexts but i want to make sure
uh we we
you know get to some good questions
captain says would you take down the jfk
assassination video if it was posted
i would say that if it's the uh that's a
great question i would say if it's uh
showing the the moment
uh at which
uh
jfk i'd say to to be consistent with
where we are in the others if it's say
the moment of the the bullet entering
him uh than being consistent with the
others and that's not something that
we'd have up matt price says if someone
wanted to post the passing of a loved
family member maybe at the request of
the family member to share their last
words would that get banned well that's
a good question
get in the nuance because this one's
kind of like
you know no it's a hospital bed
look i can tell you where a policy is uh
uh what the
what the again the the vision of this is
um
i'm not convinced entirely that uh but i
want to discuss that with the team again
it's not necessarily that i don't make
every decision in a vacuum again that's
the reason why we have this executive
team to kind of going through this one
um
but again we want to be as consistent as
possible we don't want to send people
mixed messages and say that uh and
that's that's sometimes that's you know
part of the so doing a hot take like
graphic death and murder are different
than just death itself like well it's
it's the killing the kill is is again
what it where we said the point is the
point of where you take someone's life
uh
that is the
that is the focus i i just i want to
think about this because if i if i say
one thing then people say well you know
has it been already updated or what's
going so it's uh because i i mean these
are great points but again it's the act
of taking someone's life uh at that
moment uh where we have said that this
is uh that's not what we want to show on
the platform all right so we've got um
bug off says does gutter ban all racial
nationalists regardless of color
so if it's say for example if they're
uh
one black nationalist like the nation of
islam like farrakhan he's banned um
fair khan uh yes he is someone who is uh
who is banned if you went in and used a
um you go and use a
racial slur uh against uh white people
for example yes you're gonna be kicked
off and you're gonna be banned well he
uses racial slurs for jewish people he's
particularly egregious acting and he's
not allowed on the platform but so so if
someone joined and said how many people
here support the nation of islam would
you ban them
if they want and said uh nation of islam
uh the answer is yes nation of islam is
very clearly they exist to try to uh
bring harm to people of jewish and white
backgrounds what about religious
nationalism because you mentioned that
religious groups would be protected what
if you know someone came in and said if
you're not a christian you're you're bad
you're a bad bad person and all nations
should be only christian would that be
banned
there is so
would need to look at the
the exact context i'm going to tell you
why on this there are we have plenty of
people who are on getter who say that um
your uh path to salvation
is through christ
and
uh anything else you're not going to
have unless you have the salvation
through christ that's that's the pathway
to heaven
everyone else is going to go to hell
and that is and you're talking about
that that is your um that is your your
religious belief
there's a difference uh i think between
that and
uh and same obviously i don't i'm not an
expert saying that well i'm asking about
nationals specifically like so you see
those guys who have the big signs that
say you're going to burn you're evil
you're a sinner it's very different from
like you know most people i know who are
religious you know they're like i
understand you know you have to find
your own past salvation i believe it's
this and then there are people who are
outright like
you know what what's that thing that the
templars would yell
they use vault yeah yeah they're people
who post things like that would you ban
that phrase for instance i i think where
god wills that it means where if it
comes where you are
wishing the harm to somebody else but if
you're saying here's my religious
teaching and again i can use the example
because i uh obviously have a much
better sense on the christianity part uh
that
our group say if you're saying that
through this your relationship with
christ that's how you're going to have
anyone else is going to go to hell yeah
you can you can go and post that i think
that's different if it's a difference if
you're talking about your religious
belief your religious position um but
then you're going in effectively
wishing hard than another group take
that exact statement that your path
salvation is only through you know
christ that's okay right like you are
going to go to hell if you don't believe
in christ he's your only path salvation
that's acceptable yes what if they said
something basically the exact same thing
but it was a racial connotation like you
are all going to burn
unless you support black nationalism and
black nationalism as your only pathway
to salvation would that be allowed
the
the black nationalism again if it's
i don't mean a single audience i just
mean like a racial connotation to any
race asian nationalism or whatever
so again it's uh look there is a
um where i've not done the deeper divers
on the
the racial nationalism the way because
one of the things we want to make sure
look again we're up in operating a
number of countries we have people who
are um hindu nationalists for example
that are on the platform very much uh
india is one of our big expansion
countries in fact i'm going there in
march um and we have a lot of people who
are in fact the uh the hindu ecosystem
for example is one of the big accounts
that has just joined and they're signing
up a lot of folks in india to help out
uh obviously there's a lot of strife and
turmoil with both the uh uh the hindu
and muslim communities uh both an indian
around and yeah a lot of people again
who are uh
hindu nationalists for example on the
religious side uh the racial side i
think is
different
um
i think through so say for some somebody
came in and had the albe so blm is not a
religion uh that is um political
ideology that's a political idea so i
think there's a difference between the
religion and in a political ideology on
that sense a lot of people are asking
you why you think nick fuentes is a
white nationalist
so from well a couple things um
from the
both from his the comments and things i
mean he's self-identified uh well that's
they're all denying that they they've
he's never so this is what we're getting
comments they're saying nick fuentes has
never stated that there is a race better
than another race that white people are
better
nor that he's identified as a white
nationalist nor and and i'm not saying
it's true because i don't know i'm just
telling you what the comments are asking
you
they're wondering
why you are accusing him when they say
that accusation is false well i would
say look even if someone who i'd
someone off the street who i didn't know
uh but they were making an effort to go
in and recruit well let me just ask you
have you ever seen or heard anything
from nick fuentes that was white
nationalism like have you directly heard
from him specifically
i i've have a limited volume of things
that i've uh that i've seen from nick
fuentes obviously i've seen him use some
words that would not be allowed on our
platform
uh some racial slurs that would not be
allowed on our platform uh but the point
is even if it wasn't fontes anyone else
who came in and made a similar comment
or was trying to um uh organize or pull
people together who
um in a group that's identified as
uh
who identified them as white
nationalists as far as uh on the
brighter side look i gotta be completely
honest i don't know a whole lot about
what gripers are and i'll admit it's
it's not a community i've spent a ton of
time that i've seen but um i've seen a
number of writings and things where
that's how that that group has been
defined so you're saying because the
media has called them white nationalists
you've banned
nick fuentes no i'd say that uh say for
the fact that um if you're out there
trying to organize and collect with a
group uh they don't even think it's just
immediately look at many people who've
self-id'd uh as being part of that group
or part of that ideology bro i don't
think you got an argument here man this
sounds like complete [ __ ]
i i don't think you know anything about
this group as i gotta be honest i don't
either but this is just talking in
circles
i've not listened to nick fuentes i
don't know a lot about him i know that
he's been banned across the board i know
that he's had trouble getting on planes
i can hear what his fans are saying but
i don't know
uh maybe they're just lying because they
want to support him i really don't know
so it's really difficult for me to be
like
you know to understand exactly what he
did wrong the issue for me is when i ask
you you don't seem to know either
no i i think all you said is that he
posted who else is here as a graper i'm
like well what's a graper you don't know
you just read in the media and said
something bad about them is that
justification for me i got no idea
like i i i thought you were going to
come on and be like look nick flint has
said this and he said this and you got
to understand we did research on grapers
and found this but you don't even have
that
look and i'm going to say on this that
you're not going to make everyone happy
when you're running a social media
platform and people are going to have
different opinions so your opinion uh
might be that hey that that's bs
there are other people are going to say
look these guys are making sure this is
a safe platform and we respect what
they're doing they're giving us that
ability to have that political free
speech
and look we might just disagree on this
one i just feel like look i can you know
i'll stress it again i do believe that
getter is likely to censor
less than twitter is but i also kind of
feel like
if you can't give us a direct quote from
nick fuentes that got him banned
explain to us in detail what a groper is
or how a griper is or how you know what
it is then it just sounds to me that the
moment the media you know piles up on me
or luke or anybody else you'll ban us
too no i i understand they pile up on
nick funders more than anybody else but
there's hold on hold on but
there is there is a difference between
taking a very pointed
political take uh or saying this is uh
and
going into the other direction and so
we've made very clear that we are never
going to shadow ban or algorithm or go
and use different standards for people
based on their political beliefs we've
made that very clear i i get it man but
i i mean i still don't understand why
you banned fuentes like you're saying
gripers are bad you're saying he's a
white national stuff and i'm like oh i
mean as wikipedia says that i guess but
isn't it important that you know you
guys actually have a definitive this
broke the rules like when luke asked you
what did he say that broke the rules a
lot of people are asking the same
question you never answered that
question you didn't say what rule he
broke what term specifically did he
break
and if and if you know you responded
something the fact of you know gripers
are white nationalists and they're a
hateful group and he's recruiting so you
know nation of islam would be banned as
well my response is okay what's a graper
and
so this will be and this is where i told
you i said look we should have had our
the more specific community guidelines
go into specific examples we should have
already had that posted and up that's
one of the things we're working on now
uh and we'll have that up very shortly
so it's a little more detailed because
again the terms of service are always
going to be more general because that's
your legal contract
yeah you know th this is this is uh this
kind of stuff's tough because dr malone
gets banned from twitter for talking
about his opinions as a scientist and a
researcher as an expert he goes on joe
rogan and he mentions that he's using
getter and getter allows him to be on
the platform that's correct he's dr
malone is on getter correct and he's
been on for i think month month and a
half something like that and so you know
one of the things i said about rumble is
that for the time being i think most
people should recognize
all of these platforms have similar
rules to a certain degree but there's
like certain political bubbles where
you're allowed some of the some some
more leeway than others
that being said getter i think is a net
positive
but i gotta say it's not confidence
building
that
i i know how the media is going to spend
this tim defends all right or whatever i
don't care i don't know enough about
nick fuentes to even criticize the guy
other than people have posted things
about him and accused him of things so
but i if i was running a social media
company my response would people would
come to me and be like you got to ban
this guy he's recruiting gropers i'd be
like what's a graper they'd be like the
white nationalists oh wow can you show
me a video clip of them saying and doing
these things and
that would sure like if you know you
show me that stuff and be like oh okay
maybe we have an issue with that
but i i got to be honest you know just
if that's all he posted really
look
it's crazy and and maybe look i mean
maybe this is maybe this goes in that
category from the previous one that you
mentioned that is this a uh a period of
time as opposed to um
as opposed to being indefinite that's
one of the things we'll have to go and
discuss but but again
your point tim i think
that it seems that you're getting too is
how do you know that things won't change
how do you know the rug will get pulled
out from uh from and look you can make
the same point or criticism about any
platform ultimately what you have to
point to or who are the people uh that
are on the platform uh what are the
debates that are being allowed to happen
uh that are different from other
platforms
and also i think what is your what is
your mission statement what are you
trying to accomplish and i think what we
do on that both the people on the
platform and the debates that are being
allowed to happen there i think is
different from anywhere else yeah but
free speech is free speech not for
speech that's going to keep you safe you
know and i think there's a distinction
to make here and and i think just being
you know transparent and open especially
when it comes to major decisions would
be a major step forward for any big tech
company that would reassure people
exactly what's happening behind the
scenes and the decisions why they're
made so i think that's what tim's trying
to get at yeah and i think that's i
think the the transparency part uh i
think is is very fair and i think that
uh where we want to be is better than
any of the other uh any other companies
are running social media platforms
there's a lot of things to say about
this there's deep philosophical and
moral questions notably that over time
society's moral standards change and
that may be occurring now
you look back 200 years ago and there
are things
nobody in this country would agree with
or say because morally we changed and we
changed a lot
so now you have
unification in you know a lot of social
media any any of the big players that
outright say like you know hateful
content that causes harm that seems to
be like a universal standard but it's a
standard typically among powerful elites
if it weren't for the internet
there would be no smaller voices
retaining the views and values they hold
over time the big machine would just
churn those away and the moral standard
of society would just completely flip
and there would be no say from the
peasants the lower class the plebs would
have no dis notice no no right to speak
as to what the moral standards are but
only be the elites because of social
media
people are able to retain views and
values that other people don't like and
it's it's it's breeding into this
fissure it's fracturing so i i guess to
kind of get to my point is personally i
detest and despise racism i actually am
a fan of diversity i think the woke left
has completely bastardized what
diversity is supposed to mean it's
supposed to mean that a dude from india
has in a completely different world view
and then you approach a problem from a
different angle you'll actually
better you'll be better off finding your
solutions instead the woke have turned
it into if you're a different color
you're diverse which it's just not and
honestly not even that they said the
black panther film was diverse because
it was all black people and i'm like
that's that's not diverse at all but let
me go and
say one thing here uh look i am proud of
the work that we've done with getter but
we've launched what we built this too
with four and a half million people and
i will tell you that getter is by far
the best free speech platform that uh
what about
you look at the fact our our platform is
is so much smoother and so much better
than anything out there that uh strives
to provide free speech and what we've
been able to put together i think is is
top-notch and the fact that this is
something where people are going to make
sure that we're going to make sure that
people do not have their political
voices censored as we go into whether it
be the midterms whether we're going to
2024 that this platform that we're doing
and here's everything tim
it's not just here in the us
getter is what we're going to make sure
how we protect free speech in places
like whether it be france whether it be
places like brazil maybe places like
india or anywhere else
this is the rocket ship this is the one
that's going to protect free speech and
it's the best thing that people are
going to have because here's the thing
here's again i know i said this once
before not trying to go in circles but i
got to go and make this point
we are the one company that has uh the
technology is as good or better if
anything that big tech is doing that
wakes up every day and say how do we
make sure we protect free speech and
oppose cancer culture we're the only one
that can go do that and go toe-to-toe
with big tech
i think uh you know
you know
a lot of people have mentioned gab uses
the first amendment as their standard
for um you know moderation uh i think
you know we've talked quite a bit about
this if it's the speech is legal the
speech should be allowed if um
and if it's illegal then it's illegal
and then you the moderator should take
it down and forward it to law
enforcement there's also some leeway i
think we can make like doxing for
instance doxxing is another thing that's
listed specifically in the terms of
service work and i'll tell you there's
universally like despised you know i
mean look there's again it's
it's something serious obviously we took
the post down but there's a certain
reporter that always uh makes very
personal comments about me that i really
don't like um and someone posted the
fact that he lives with his parents and
here's the address obviously the second
we saw that that thing came down and
that person was uh suspended and you
can't you know
never do that um so no the doxing stuff
is there but you know the one other
thing to keep in mind too um is that
also we have uh we're we're playing
globally here so we also have so for
example that's what jack dorsey said to
me
it's a reality it doesn't just i mean
look jack's not wrong at every single
thing they said i mean for example if
you you know
a woman wearing a skirt uh that goes
above the knee in the u.s no one even
glances twice uh you do that in saudi
arabia then okay
but let's get to the root of this
problem what's what's stopping you guys
from implementing a platform that
prioritizes free speech in the united
states and does it the way that tim was
describing what what's standing in the
way
well a couple things it's well number
one what we're trying to grow is we're
trying to grow a global company where
people can have free speech and can have
that right defended regardless of where
they are because it's not just a uh
everything
hold on it's not free speech though who
does free speech
if someone has a negative opinion about
a person of another religion or race
they're not allowed to say that
so i can you could a guy can walk
outside
you know in in the in the middle of a
city and hold up the most awful sign
because free speech is a guaranteed
right but on your platform that's not
the case hold on if you wanted to give
me the criticism that what we have is is
political free speech but you say that
it's not 100 i'll be the first one to
say
it's not 100 no platform out because
there are people even who say
um
let me just officially just one thought
there are some people who say that any
restriction even if it's legal or
illegal is not free speech some people
go out there i've had people in
arguments and debates who've brought
that up but what i'm going to say is so
but if you were to say that hey what i'm
i'm hearing here is that you have
political free speech
um well that's a fair criticism uh but
you know what this is the best place for
free speech you have anywhere on the
planet and i will fight tooth and nail
to make that point over and over derrick
bell are you familiar with him i'm not
one of the uh
proponents and original authors in
critical race theory
he his political opinion is that
the united states should have never uh
passed the civil rights act he advocates
for a policy of separate but equals a
black man who believes that white people
and black people should be segregated
would you allow him on the platform to
ask you know his followers to to come
and follow and all that stuff that's a
direct political policy position
uh i would need i would need to get a
little bit of a more granular
understanding of what he's saying so so
um
uh i could be mixing this up his his
stance was that the ruling from the
supreme court of separate but equal
according to derek bell
was correct and this is one of the big
views among black lives matter and uh
critical race theory proponents they
feel that
there was a separate economy for the
black community that was struck that was
thriving that was that was
you know growing and that the end of the
the civil rights era effectively merged
the two economies but because white
people had historical power were able to
oppress with the greater power the black
community so he's advocated for a return
or or i should say never allowing the
desegregation as a policy position
if someone went on your platform and
said i believe we should here's a good
question uh california recently had a
proposition that would have stricken the
civil rights language from their
constitution would you allow the
democrats on getter to advocate for the
repealing of california's civil rights
provision
i would need to go take a look at that a
little bit more and that's a tough thing
with with some of the hypotheticals
overtly allowing for the discrimination
based on race
well obviously if you were if you were
out there advocating for the the blatant
discrimination purely based on race and
that's that's not something so harvard
is banned from getter
i would say if harvard overtly has
policies discriminating on bases of race
like uh sat scores for admittance for
asians have to be higher than white
people um have to be way higher than
white people admitting scores right
people have to be higher than black
people but hold on you're uh
again i would need to go and see that
just because i haven't seen harvard's
writing um or what exactly that paul i
didn't get into harvard uh sorry guys um
i would need to go and see that exactly
but you know to the point if you're
advocating
racial discrimination uh not something
saying like a court because one of the
things that can't speak to not being a
lawyer is this this policy was uh this
court case was ruled incorrectly
i'm not a lawyer i'm not going to go to
the supreme court but if you're someone
who's going insane advocating for uh
racial discrimination against against
whites or against blacks or against
anybody that's not something we would
allow so we got to go to the members uh
you know podcast and i want to make a
quick couple quick quick points i wish
this conversation was being had with
twitter's people which is a massive
international platform and so i greatly
respect your willingness to come on and
have us just like throw these hard
questions at you that are probably
difficult there's a lot of people who
are angry i feel like we're all spraying
you with hoses right now
all at the same time but but look look
look you're at least willing to have the
conversation and i've been sprayed
plenty of times so and i do think that
getter is less likely to censor than
twitter case in point
malone but
i think the challenge is
it's impossible to navigate this space
unless you just say legal speech is
allowed because you know when you say
i'm not going to allow fuentes because
you know these these positions
discriminating all of a sudden it opens
the door to the principle
critical race theorists the woke are
overtly racist you know based on what
you've said
you should never allow any of them on
your platform at not even not even one
of them sean king banned outright i mean
uh tariq nasheed banned out right hassan
banned out right hassan has has actually
he got suspended from twitch for saying
racial slurs so if he signed up for
getter you'd ban the biggest left-wing
live streamer from your platform it
seems if it's someone if it's someone
coming in who's who's advocating uh
racial discrimination that's what left
does
again it's there are people who are
uh there's difference between a jerk and
being an idiot and somebody who's
outright uh advocating for racial
discrimination
they literally do the corporate media
but here's
tim i look not trying to go in circles
so pushing yeah i know no but hold on
but here's here's one thing that i kind
of do want to pick this little bit of a
fight with you even though it's your
house you've invited me and i appreciate
that let's have a conversation here's
the thing i want to pick the fight on is
that
what i'm trying to offer people
is a product
where they're going to be safe
from the oppression of big tech
it started small okay they kicked off
president trump you get half the country
who hated him for it half the country
who liked him for it
then it's kind of the the frog in the
the water that's getting hot and hotter
they start chipping away this they start
saying you can't say where kovid came
from
they said that you can't criticize his
lord and savior dr anthony fauci they
said you can't go and post the hunter
biden story then they go and kick off
trump then they go and say you can't
even talk about covid or lockdowns or
any of these things
if i
again not trying to be rude well i'm in
your house if i took the opinion
that or the belief that you can't go and
change this you can't give people a
place where they can fight for their
political values
then i'd never get anywhere we'd be we'd
be at zero users not four and a half i
might be at four and a half million
people now i'm going to take this thing
to 10 by the middle a year to 20 or 20
million by the end of the year and you
know what these are people when they go
into their respective elections they
know no one's going to come in and say
your ideology is fine different you ca
the points that you're bringing up are
many of them
i mean they're important because they're
the foundation of our first amendment
what counts as free speech
what what counts what are you using for
your basis your guideline how do we know
that this isn't going to be turned
around on us
but i do think that it can be successful
and i think for what most people want to
do what they view their free speech
would talk about again no one's ever
come to me said if i could just use this
one particular slur then i would count
you as being okay if i could just say
this one thing threatening harm
then your platform would be okay i do
push back on the notion that
that it can't be successful
i i think it very much can i i think i
think getter is going to be great
greatly successful i think it's a net
positive we've got to fight success
exactly no no no no no no no no no no no
no fiscal success
like what's the goal we've definitely
gotta wind things down because we're
going long which which is which is not a
bad thing but i just want to you know i
can define i can define success but
we'll we'll we'll take it to the members
only and we'll you know we'll get more
details is that enough of a teaser
uh it's gonna be it's gonna be an
excellent members only podcast uh
i just i wanna make sure everyone knows
as we wind down that i think getter is
is is is an is a massive net positive
and we don't have the opportunity to
challenge big tech the way we have you
sitting here answering these questions
and so instead of you know getting
directing anger towards you to a greater
degree than we would jack dorsey i think
anybody who's upset about nick fuentes
especially should probably
roll their eyes
get frustrated and be like here are my
complaints here's here are my issues
with this
we recognize big tech is substantially
worse look take the win if uh i know
it's i know it's it's it's you know a
lot of people are upset about about
fuentes particularly but if we can make
sure that dr malone has a voice and we
can gain some ground back in free speech
i'll take it i'm not going to be
completely happy with you know some of
the rules i'm concerned about but i get
i think getter is better than twitter in
that capacity and
the one thing i'd add on that it's not
some ground it's making sure that people
have that right because if you don't
think
that twitter and facebook and big tech
that their goal isn't to for example not
just trump because it's not just all
trump people largely trump people that
they wouldn't be fine completely with
having every trump voter or conservative
or populist
kicked off their platform they're
totally because you know what they say
hey let's go to other countries we'll
just go and sign people up we can get i
mean look india is facebook's biggest
market they've already made that
calculation that they are fine to lose
anyone right of center not just in the
us when facebook said they're expanding
their global
anti-misinformation board which is again
that's one thing i wish
i do think the conversation got tilted a
little bit too much into
some of the the fuentes stuff whereas
when we talk about the the editing and
censoring for example we don't put up
warning labels because then that's going
into the editorializing we're never
gonna get to the point where it's like
well we think it's okay we're gonna have
the post up there but or it's not okay
but we're gonna allow the post up
because then you're editorializing
they facebook is intentionally ramping
up their efforts in the philippines in
colombia in brazil in france uh and even
in uh hungary has their elections coming
up in the us in the midterms we're going
to make sure we want to define success
that people whether you're on the right
or if you're on the left in any country
around the world you're going to have
access to free speech and making your
political voice heard and nobody is
going to shut you down that's how i
define success we got to go to the
members podcast if you ever have if you
have not already smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.com sign
up because we're gonna have that members
only uh episode hopefully around 11. it
might go long because we're having a
really good conversation you can follow
the show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me at timcast
basically everywhere instagram and
getter uh jason you want to shout out uh
your your social media
your literal social media social media
so at jason miller in dc uh you can get
me on getter i usually spend a lot of
time
responding to folks at night going
through the user comments i think it's
important that anyone who's gonna go put
their name on a platform is very in
touch with the different comments and
things that are going on i appreciate
the feedback look people through some
tough questions i think some good ideas
particularly on the pathway to
forgiveness i think was uh and better
articulating some of the points on
transparency i think were important uh i
think that's good and i think you you're
number one you're not going to get
anyone else going to come in and like i
said whether go sit down with the care
swisher tim poole and uh and go through
this um look
we might not get it right 100 of the
time that's always the goal i don't
think i'll be able to get someone like
jack dorsey or you will see you have
twitter to come on here because i'm not
gonna baby you know you could always
just meet him in person like i used to
do but that's a whole nother story
anyway i got a gajillion questions but
thank you for answering the ones that
you did
we'll continue with the members only so
yeah we'll continue that i have my own
independent media organization lots of
crazy news coming out of the czech
republic in england i talked about that
on youtube.com forward slash we are
change and then of course i talked about
my strategy moving forward specifically
on luke uncensored.com hope to see some
of you guys there this was a great
conversation we need more of these and
there's always solutions to these
problems that we're bringing up maybe we
could come to a consensus and bring more
transparency accountability and even a
process where a lot of this could be
solved uh so i i'm hopeful i'm
optimistic the conversation has started
we're going to take it to some good
places i think oh yeah i got a lot of
respect for you man and what you guys
are doing that's a big a big ass thank
you um and i want to help so there's a
reason i bring up free software because
i would love to integrate a bunch of
networks like rumble and mines and
getter and gap into like a mega do union
can i give one extra tease for the
members only part one thing i want to go
to because we didn't get much in the
functionality we kept it a little more
on the um uh the philosophical and in
theoretical side
uh
one of the things that's going to set us
apart from other platforms addition to
the longer post longer videos the live
streaming we have right now a million
people watch president trump's uh rally
last saturday on getter which is that's
nuts four and a half million people on a
platform a million we're watching that
we'll be launching in february where we
call vision which will be our short
video competitor to tick tock and
instagram reels so right now people can
say oh getter their competitor to
twitter
month and a half two months from now
smaller competitor initially i'll grant
you that but we will look at ourselves
as a competitor to tick tock and
instagram reels when we go into the
summer that's what we're going to go
into in the members session we're going
to launch getter pay which will be a
payment platform similar to apple pay
alipay those but hold on here's the
thing this is why you got to come to the
members section
it's going to be a 2 it's going to be a
two coin uh uh ecosystem two coin uh
crypto ecosystem with a stable coin and
a fluctuating coin that's come in the
summer we're giving people the freedom
of speech freedom of expression freedom
of their financial destiny no one else
has done this anyone knows what libra
what facebook was trying to do for years
the reason i couldn't do it because
zuckerberg just for like a bad term
sucks i can say that on youtube i don't
think they'll block that out but for the
fact that nobody believed in it they
didn't believe that they had a vision or
place where they wanted to go are making
sure that people have political free
speech i think that's credibility and
you look to this summer when we launch
this we're going to expose people and
bring the digital economy to them in a
crypto way that no social media platform
has ever done come to the members
section we're going to granular on it oh
thanks uh ian crossland.net check it out
catch it see you later
thank you so much for coming on jason i
did tell you you were going to get
grilled and i was not lying but i do
want to say that i'm really glad that we
have some of these other options and i
hope that people will continue to give
positive feedback and kind of help
develop and make this into something
great and hopefully we can really really
offer some good competition for twitter
uh and facebook thank you so much for
coming again you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids we will see you
all over at timcast.com at about 11 p.m
with the members only segment where we
get into a lot more questions some
people are wondering what about furries
you'll find out at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you